Irgendjemand hat in den Kommentaren geschrieben, wie der Film dazu hieß. Ich hab ja letztes Mal Channel 4 News Team, warte mal ich such den Film mal raus.
Was, was, was, was?
Ich hab doch beim letzten Mal gesagt, das klingt wie beim Channel 4 News Team und ich bin aber nicht mehr auf den Namen des Films gekommen. Ich komm auch jetzt nicht auf den Namen des Films.
Ich spiel das Ding übrigens nicht, weil ich der Meinung bin, das wäre ein guter Intro für Mobile Max. Ich spiel das einfach nur, damit uns irgendwie klar ist, dass jetzt die Sendung anfängt.
Genau. Anchorman, The Legend of Ron Burgundy. So heißt der Film. Kann man sich gut mal geben.
Die Legende von Ron Burgundy. Ist das so eine Legende?
Nee, quatsch, überhaupt nicht. Das ist halt elender Klamauk-Film. Wenn ich noch kitten würde, würde ich sagen, es ist ein Kiffer-Film.
Aber das tust du ja nicht.
Aber das tue ich ja nicht.
Schon gar nicht heute, schon gar nicht hier, weil wir ja hier on Air sind. Wieder mal viel zu spät, in viel zu kleiner Besetzung und viel zu verpeilt und viel zu schlecht vorbereitet. Wie es hier die Regel ist, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ihr uns überhaupt überhaupt noch zuhört. Ich bin ein großer Kritiker unserer Sendung geworden.
Ist dir das bewusst? Das andere hätte mich entsetzt. Wenn du irgendwas gut finden würdest, ich meine, wir sind ja schließlich nicht von Apple.
Genau, wir haben noch nicht mal den Vorhang zugemacht. Das klingt wie Sau. Ich finde, die Kommentatoren halten sich ganz schön zurück. Andere Podcast klagen darüber, was sie sich für ein Troil-Material eingefangen haben. Aber bei uns sind ja immer noch alle ganz lieb.
Das liegt daran, dass wir ungefähr jeden 80 Prozent aller Kommentare löschen.
Nein.
Das hast du gesagt. Um mir jetzt Gerüchte vorzubeugen, ich glaube, ich habe noch nie einen Kommentar gelöscht, der nicht eindeutig Spam war.
Ja, dazu ist das ja auch da. Ich muss da auch in meinem Blog umstellen, auf jeden Kommentar einzeln freischalten, weil ich sonst einfach diesem Spam-Problem nicht mehr herwerde. Diese ganzen Archismet und sonstigen Spam-Teile.
Also, bei Mobile Max geht es eigentlich.
Ja, es wundert mich. Aber irgendwie in meinem Blog ist es alles ganz furchtbar und grauenhaft. Und die Falls, wie nennt man das?
Falls Positives?
Also wenn einem Spam sozusagen, wenn Spam nicht erkannt wird und automatisch freigeschaltet wird. Ich will sozusagen gar nicht erst, dass er überhaupt auftaucht.
Das ist ja mittlerweile, also das zum einen klar, das ist relativ häufig, aber so diese Leute, die, ah super, ich hab vergessen, mein Telefon auszuschalten, diese Leute, die, die jetzt immer mehr kommen, bei uralten Artikeln noch einen halbwegs sinnvollen Kommentar drunter schreiben, aber es geht eigentlich ihnen offensichtlich nur darum, da ihren Link unterzubringen. Diese Form von Spam, die nimmt ja gigantisch zu. Also Leute, die vom Arbeitsamt empfohlen kriegen, doch sich selbstständig zu machen und mal Kommentare in Blogs zu schreiben, das ist wohl tatsächlich so.
Ernsthaft?
Das passiert wohl tatsächlich. Irgendjemand hat mal, ich weiß leider nicht, wer es war, der hat in seinem Blog, der hat jemand abgemahnt. Also der hat halt einen Satz reingeschrieben, alles klar, kommerzielle Kommentare, überhaupt kein Problem, macht 500 Euro pro Stück und der ist dann halt auf die Webseite drauf, hat in der Presse nachgeguckt, hat den Typen angerufen, hat ihn angefangen zuäumeln und der es am Telefon direkt zusammengebrochen hat, gesagt, oh Gott, oh Gott, ich bin doch ja so, und selbstständig und die Frau vom Arbeitsamt hat gesagt, ich soll doch hier mal so im Internet ein paar Voren und in Blogs und so Kommentare reinschreiben und ein bisschen Werbung dafür machen. Kein Witz. Also vielleicht hat er auch Bullshit erzählt.
Tolle Methode.
Die Leute vom Arbeitsamt loszuwerden. Mann, die selbstständigen und Spam sind ein bisschen.
So, das Arbeitsamt ist sozusagen die Hauptquelle von Spam heutzutage. Das ist ja wirklich was Neues. So, wie auch immer, haben wir jetzt die Hörer schon ordnungsgemäß begrüßt? Sind wir heute eigentlich ganz lieb zueinander?
Mal sehen. Ich guck mal, ob ich eine Waffe da habe, um mich selbst zu verteidigen.
Haben wir uns wieder ein bisschen in den Haaren gehabt. Das gehört dazu. Ist nicht so ein Weichei-Podcast, wo immer alles irgendwie wischiwaschi und schmusi schmusi ist und wir sind schon irgendwie alle einer Meinung und so. Bis aufs Blut.
Doch, wir sind immer einer Meinung.
Ist das so? Okay, also heute sind wir alle einer Meinung. Mal gucken, welche Meinung da war.
So, wir sind mal wieder nur zu zweit. Das soll man vielleicht dazu erwähnen.
Genau, wir sind zu zweit aus unklaren Gründen.
Also Huckel ist krank?
Huckel ist krank und Dennis ist wahrscheinlich wieder im Fnord, wie üblich. Aber das soll uns jetzt einfach nicht weiter kümmern, denn wir haben uns mal aus einer Vielzahl von Vorschlägen, die leider im Wesentlichen so aus kleinen Gerüchten, News-Bits besteht. Das ist irgendwie, ist nicht so unser Ding, oder? Ich meine, wir könnten jetzt über 1000, was war das alles wieder, was irgendwas irgendwie vielleicht hat oder vielleicht auch nicht unterhalten. Aber ich finde, damit verbringt man einfach die Zeit falsch. Wir sollten lieber uns auf das Konkrete stürzen.
Über Videokodex reden.
Unter anderem. Aber anfangen wollten wir mit einem ganz spannenden Thema.
Ich muss mich outen.
Du bist ja, das ist ja auch deine Rolle so ein bisschen hier auch jetzt schon.
Ich bin ja, ich weiß.
Ich will mal alles gut finden, was nicht Apple ist. Ach Palme ist doch toll, Android und jetzt Windows 7.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich es toll finde.
Ich bin nur auf alles vorbereitet.
Ach so, du bist auf alles vorbereitet. Ja, ich gehe jetzt seit ein paar Monaten der Festanstellungen nach. Am Anfang habe ich auf meinem MacBook gearbeitet und habe mich breitschlagen lassen, weil wir haben jetzt für unsere Desktop-Rechner SSDs bekommen, damit die schneller sind und irgendwann wird es ein Eilband. Wenn du mit deinem Privatrechner da rumsitzt, wenn du da wirklich so ein Monster rumstehen hast, also ein Monster ist es jetzt nicht, ich hatte Core 2 Duo mit 4 GB RAM, aber eben eine 64 GB SSD drin, die übrigens überhaupt nichts bringt, wenn man einen sehr restriktiven Virenscanner drauf hat.
Wie, die SSD bringt nichts, wenn man einen restriktiven Virenscanner drauf hat?
Die Virenscanner sind da standardmäßig so eingestellt, dass...
Wir sind jetzt schon bei Windows.
Wir sind schon bei Windows, genau. Wir haben Rechner bekommen mit SSDs, also wir haben SSDs eingebaut in die Kisten. Zusätzlich oder ausschließlich? Zusätzlich, aber halt als primäre Platte. Also die andere, die...
Da, wo das Windows drauf ist?
Da, wo das Windows drauf ist, da wo alle Programme drauf sind, alles ist drauf im Augenblick. Also im Augenblick nutze ich die normale 3,5-Zwei-Platte nicht. Und da haben wir Windows 7 drauf gebügelt und jetzt sind alle weg. Und... Alle total begeistert. Naja, nee, total begeistert nicht. Weil es schnell ist? Es ist nicht so schlimm, wie man... Also erstens, schnell war es am Anfang wirklich überhaupt nicht. Wegen diesem Vionscanner, den wir da drauf haben. Jetzt haben wir rausgekriegt, wie man den Vionscanner... Also wir können den Vionscanner nicht abschalten. Aber weil wir Administratorenrechte auf unserem Rechner haben, können wir den Vionscanner einfach umbenennen, sodass er beim Start nicht mehr hochfährt.
Umbenennen?
Du nennst die Datei einfach anders. Man findet das nicht mehr und dann hat er halt keinen Vionscanner. Man findet den nicht mehr.
Was macht denn der Vionscanner die ganze Zeit?
Bei jedem Schreiben und Lesen wird jede Datei durchgescannt.
Das ist...
Was?
Krank. Das ist mal kein Deutschsteller. Das war wirklich... Aber jetzt mit SSD und Vionscanner abgeschaltet, ist es tatsächlich schneller?
Ist das eine übliche Konfiguration mit Windows?
Offensichtlich. Also ich hab keine Ahnung, aber offensichtlich sieht es so aus. Also es ist... Sagen alle, dass das nämlich paranoid ist.
Aber...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das üblich ist.
Oder ob paranoia angemessen ist.
Nee, sowohl nicht, weil es da noch nie ein Problem mit Viren gab. Ja, da ist halt jemand, der ist halt jemand vom Helpdesk, der ist immer noch bezuständig, dass die Rechner sicher sind. Und dann sagt er, bin ich mal ein bisschen paranoid.
Okay, also du hast auf jeden Fall Sicherheit versus Performance. Du hast dich entschlossen für Performance.
Wir haben probiert, die Performance rauszubuchen.
Und hast einfach mal den Virenscanner umbenannt.
Genau.
Wie heißt der jetzt?
McAfee aus.
Und dann?
Und jetzt ist das halbwegs schnell, aber nicht so schnell, wie ich gedacht hätte. Also ich dachte, das wäre so SSD. Kriegt man immer diese Videos, wo dann ja, und das Betriebssystem fährt jetzt in 14 Sekunden hoch und Programme einmal klicken und sie sind da. Ganz so schnell ist das nicht. Aber es ist schon deutlich schneller.
Hab ich dir neulich erzählt, dass ich... Eine Freundin von mir hat irgendwie quasi dasselbe MacBook. Also ich hab jetzt ein Schwarzer. Er hat das auch in Schwarz. Also zwar sozusagen gleiche Generation, aber er hat eine SSD drin gehabt. Also Only. Und es war absurd viel schneller. Also es war gefühlt dreimal so schnell.
Ja, doch, doch.
Also bootet scheiße schnell, lockt einfach ein, die Programme fliegen nur so aus dem Dock raus, irgendwie auf dem Bildschirm. Also vor allem auch keine H-Klar mehr. Das war alles sehr flüssig. So wie man sich das eigentlich wünscht.
Also was ja geil ist, wenn man so den gesamten Quellcode, das sind irgendwie über einen Gigabyte an Quellcode und den komplett zu durchsuchen, das ist eine Sache von 20 Sekunden. Ach so, deinen Quellcode.
Der hat schon bei Windows 7.
Das geht jetzt auch als Platz.
Gut, aber du wolltest ja eigentlich nicht über SSDs reden, sondern du wolltest ja eigentlich über Windows 7 reden.
Darum arbeite ich jetzt ein bisschen mit Windows 7. Es ist nicht alles schlecht. Es war nicht alles schlecht, aber es sind wirklich solche haarsträubenden Sachen dabei, wo man sich fragt, hat da irgendjemand mal auch dran gearbeitet an dem Ding? Also sie haben jetzt unten so ein Doc, also diese Windows-Taskleiste, was früher Taskleiste hieß. Das heißt jetzt auch Doc. Nee, das heißt immer noch Windows-Taskleiste. Aber es sieht aus wie ein Doc. Also links hat es so diesen Windows-Button, der ist jetzt bloß halt rund und nicht mehr eckig. Dann waren ja immer die einzelnen Fenster aufgezählt, die man so draufklickern konnte. Die sind jetzt so zu Icons zusammengefasst. Und wenn du auf so ein Programm-Icon draufklickst, dann startet halt das Programm. Und wenn das Programm schon läuft, dann wird das Programm in den Vordergrund geholt, außer wenn das Programm zwei Fenster offen hat. Weil wenn man dann auf ein Programm-Icon draufklickt, dann wird das Programm ausgeblendet. Und das ist wirklich so was, dass...
Was nochmal, das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Also du hast ein Programm, das läuft. So wie auf dem Mac. Du siehst das Icon. Also wenn ich jetzt meinen Safari-Icon im Doc anklicke, unter Windows passiert exakt das gleiche auf dem Mac, solange ich nur ein Fenster aufhabe. In Safari. Sobald Safari zwei Fenster aufhört, und ich auf das Icon in der Status-Leiste klicke, wird Safari ausgeblendet. Wenn ich dann nochmal draufklicke, wird es wieder eingeblendet. Aber nicht im Vordergrund, sondern auf derselben Ebene, auf der es schon vorher zu sehen war. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendein Programm im Fullscreen-Modus habe, und ich will durch Klick auf dieses Icon in ein anderes Programm wechseln, dann passiert gar nichts, weil ich nicht sehe, wie das Programm im Hintergrund ausgeblendet wird und dann wieder eingeblendet wird. Bloß weil in Firefox versehentlich zwei Fenster offen sind.
Zum Beispiel.
Davon hängt das ab. Manche Programme sagen auch, hey, dieses Programm läuft schon und machen ansonsten auch gar nichts. Also kommt dann auch nicht in den Vordergrund.
Jetzt fangen wir uns wahrscheinlich wieder eine große Menge an Kommentaren an, die sagen, das kann man alles einstellen, das kann man alles abschalten.
Also wenn ja, ich bin da für jeden Tipp sehr, sehr dankbar, wie man das anders konfigurieren kann, weil so ist es wirklich haarsträubend.
Aber wie hat das denn geschmeckt?
Das war's?
Ja, wie fühlt sich dein Bauch an, wenn du damit arbeitest?
Also was ich erstmal erschreckend fand, wie sich meine Hand angefühlt hat. Ich konnte meine Hand nicht mehr bewegen. Ich hab mich unglaublich an dieses Trackpad von meinem MacBook gewöhnt. Also ich kann nicht mehr mit einer Maus arbeiten.
Na gut, das ist ja jetzt nicht Windows-spezifisch.
Das ist nicht Windows-spezifisch, aber es ist Mac-spezifisch. Also das ist auch die Hardware. Ich hab mir dann so eine Tastatur mit eingebautem Trackpad gekauft, die aussieht wie so eine Laptop-Tastatur, aber auch das ist nicht dasselbe, weil das Trackpad ist natürlich viel kleiner. Also das fühlt sich erstmal total scheiße an. Mit dem Rest kommt man irgendwie klar. Teilweise sind es einfach nur Umgewöhnungs-Sachen, aber teilweise sind es halt wirklich kleine fickrige Nervigkeiten, die wirklich so schlimm sind, dass man sich sagt, wo man jedes Mal wieder davor setzt, dass man sich denkt, ach Leute, das müsst ihr doch gesehen haben, als ihr das gemacht habt. Also eine Alternative dazu wäre, dass ihr ein perfektes Betriebssystem gemacht habt und dann um dem Markenkern gerichtet zu werden, noch so ein paar haarsträubende Fehler eingebaut habt. Na das zum Beispiel, wenn du den Rechner ausschaltest und es laufen noch Programme, dann macht er so wie auf dem Mac, probiert er die Programme zu beenden und manche dieser Programme wollen auch noch eine Datei sichern und dann ploppt dieser Dialog auf, dass hey, ich möchte gerne eine Datei sichern. Dann sagt er nach ungefähr zehn Sekunden, während das Fenster in diesem Zustand ist, wird der gesamte Bildschirm schwarz oder so halbtransparent, schwarz-halbtransparent und es erscheint ein Dialog, das Programm so und so konnte nicht beendet werden. Soll ich sofort abschießen? Dann darf man ausgehen, dass es hängt. Dann hast du zwei Möglichkeiten, Programm sofort beenden oder ausschalten, abbrechen. Du siehst aber noch den Dialog. Du siehst den Dialog, in dem drin steht, hier klick mich an und sichern und alles ist gut. Du kannst aber nicht draufklicken, weil dieses Fenster halt einfach über den gesamten Bildschirm geht.
Man kann da nicht mehr hinwechseln?
Man kann nicht mehr danebenklicken.
Das heißt, du musst das Ausschalten dann abbrechen?
Du musst das Ausschalten abbrechen, dann machst du das Fenster dazu, dann sagst du wieder ausschalten, dann kommt das nächste Programm, was gesichert werden möchte. Auf dem Mac ist das schon echt manchmal nervig, wenn man das Ding ausschalten will. Und dann sagt der dann auch nach einer Weile, Ausschalten wurde abgebrochen, weil das Programm so und so nicht beendet werden konnte. Der bricht halt gleich ab? Er bricht halt nicht ab, sondern er lässt sich in diesen Zwischenzustand hängen, der einfach nur total nervig ist. Ich meine, der Mac bricht halt gleich ab. Aber er bricht nach einer Minute ab. Also du hast relativ viel Zeit, noch das Fenster zuzumachen und alles ordnungsgemäß zu beenden. Bei Windows ist es wirklich so, du siehst diesen Dialog aufploppen, alles klar, und kommst nicht dazu, draufzuklicken. Weil schon in dem Moment sagt er, ich glaube, das Programm hängt. Nein, das hängt nicht, das will nur sichern. Das hat eine legitime Frage.
Musst du da jetzt wirklich täglich mit arbeiten? Du wirst wohl sehr gut bezahlt?
Gut genug, um das über sich hinzulassen, ja. Ich probier's mal.
Da müsste man mir schon eine Menge zahlen.
Ganz so viel, wie man dir zahlen müsste, muss man mir wahrscheinlich dafür nicht zahlen. Ich bin auch noch unentschieden. Kann auch durchaus sein, dass ich einfach sage, ich nehme da weiterhin einfach mein MacBook oder ich sag denen, äh, äh.
Ich meine, wozu ist denn das überhaupt gut, dieser Rechner? Ich meine, wozu benutze den? Zum Entwickeln?
Zum Entwickeln, ja.
Also du hast keine freie Wahl der Mittel irgendwie.
Ich hab da einfach immer meinen Rechner genommen.
Ja, der steht da halt so noch so rum, oder was?
Nee, den hab ich dann in der Tasche.
Ich meine, dieser PC steht dann halt noch so rum.
Dann stünde der PC halt so rum, aber wenn er halt ein PC ist, mit einer fetten SSD drin und allen Pipapo und zwei Bildschirmen und weiß ja toll was, dann hab ich mir gedacht, naja, kann man ja auch mal benutzen.
Das probierst du jetzt?
Das probier ich jetzt gerade aus.
Und wie lange probierst du das jetzt schon?
Ähm, anderthalb Wochen.
Okay, das ist ja noch nicht so viel Zeit.
Das ist noch nicht so viel Zeit.
Dann können wir ja nächstes Mal nochmal gucken.
Dann kann ich durchaus eine Chance geben, ja. Nächstes Mal sag ich dann, ja, ich hab mir mein Windows 7-Phone bestellt. Das wird bestimmt ganz toll.
Wir schauen dann einfach mal, wie weit du dann schon assimiliert bist.
Genau. Ach und was total nervig ist, ist ja so dieses, ähm, es gibt ja nichts dafür für dieses Windows. Ich hab gar keine Programme für. Da gibt's überhaupt nichts.
Doch, das ist die führende Plattform weltweit.
Ja, ja, bestimmt. Es ist was lustiges.
Was meinst du damit da, es gibt nichts dafür?
Naja, so die übliche Shell. Hey, ich mach mal rasch ein Terminal auf. Es gibt kein Terminal. Na, es gibt diese Kommando-Zeilen-Dings, Bumstah.
Ne, Command, irgendwie Excel.
Command, Excel, genau. Und dann startest du die und dann hast du da keine Bash oder sowas, natürlich, sondern dann hast du da irgendwie PowerShell oder weißt-der-Teufel-was mit Befehlen, die keine Sau kennt.
Es ist DOS?
Ja, es ist quasi DOS. Aber in dieser Shell geht auch nichts. Also, die hat keine Suchfunktion. Ne, es ist DOS. Es gibt auch dieses berühmte SSH Client der Wahl. Also, es ist ja nicht so, dass man einfach das Terminal aufmacht und SSH startet und dann hat man SSH. Dann braucht man ein extra Programm. Das heißt PuTTY. Das ist so die übliche Freeware.
PuTTY ist ganz furchtbar.
Und PuTTY ist das Grauen. Wie arbeitet ihr damit Leute? Und auch PuTTY hat keine Suchfunktion. So dieses, mach mal kurz einen Cut auf ein File, auf ein Server und einfach mal darin suchen. Apple F oder Control F oder Alt S oder Windows F.
Also, da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Kommandozeile geht nur unter Unix. Ich glaube ernsthaft, dass Kommandozeilen unter Windows benutzen, das ist ein Mythos.
Ja, aber selbst wenn ich mich auf meiner VM einlogge und dann eine Bash habe, habe ich kein Terminal-Programm, mit dem ich...
Achso, du meinst, du kannst in diesem Terminal-Programm, also das, was dir in der GUI das Terminal aufmacht...
Genau, das bietet keinerlei Funktion.
Na, weil man ja nie drin arbeitet.
Hat man halt nicht.
Warum soll man denn da noch Funktionen einbauen?
So, dann hab ich mir Cygwin installiert, von dem wir immer alle sagen, das macht so ein Unix-Unterbau. Genau, da kommt's gerade im Chat, Cygwin kann das alles. Cygwin kann das nicht. Das ist eine Lüge. Cygwin kann das wirklich. Das ist erstmal die Dateilstruktur. Natürlich ist es immer noch ein Fremdkörper auf einem Windows-Betriebssystem. Man kriegt einen deutlichen Unterschied mit, ob man da jetzt ein Betriebssystem hat, was für eine vernünftige Shell gemacht ist, oder ob man ein Windows hat, wo in einem Verzeichnis ein Bash drinnen liegt, mit dem man dann so ein bisschen arbeiten kann. Das zweite ist, dass auch die, wenn ich auch Cygwin starte, habe ich genau dieses gleiche CMD-Punkt-Exit-Fenster. Mit dem einzigen Unterschied, dass es auch die Einstellungen aus irgendeinem Grund nicht abspeichern kann. Auch da habe ich keine Suche, kein Copy-Paste, kein gar nichts. Das ist wirklich...
Also du rufst gerade alte Erinnerungen in mir hoch, weil ich... Ich habe ja auch mal...
Ach, du hast mal... So kommt es auch mal raus.
Ich habe tatsächlich auch mal unter DOS Software entwickelt.
Ach.
Ja, das ist schon echt lange her.
Richtig nativ, oder?
Na, mit Borland, Tobuzi?
Doch?
So richtig unter DOS noch? Oder war das schon Windows?
1900? Das muss ich echt überlegen, ey.
Wann war denn das?
Ende der 80er Jahre muss das gewesen sein. Wann gab es denn TOC? Äh, ja, das war irgendwie so 1989, 1990 vielleicht? 1991? Da gab es noch nicht so richtig Windows, oder? Das war kein Windows. Genau, mit noch richtig eigene GUI machen und Pipapo und das war irgendwie alles textbasiert und Masken und so. Das war so ein Anzeigenerfassungssystem, hab ich programmiert.
Ein Anzeigenerfassungssystem? Genau.
Also wo so Leute an so Terminals sitzen und für so eine Kleinanzeigenfirma, die so ein Kleinanzeigenblatt rausbringt, also Draht, Hannover, Niedersachsen, das so was, die zweite Hand in Berlin ist und so, hat ja so jede Region ihr eigenes Ding. Und es war schon ganz sophisticated, so mit einem Datenbank-Server und Pipapo und irgendwie ISAM-Records wegschreiben und so. Da hab ich irgendwie dieses C-Tree benutzt, das kennt jetzt wieder kein Schwein, egal, worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, ich erinnere mich jetzt, wo du das sagst, dass ich damals schon unter DOS mir auch so ein Unix-Simulationstoolset installiert habe. Ich hab versucht, mich die ganze Zeit daran zu erinnern, wie das heißt. Also damals gab es alles noch gar nicht, aber es gab irgendwie so eine Bude, die halt genau so was, ah ja genau, MK-Tools hieß das glaube ich. Und das war halt genau so was, der Versuch, möglichst nahe Unix-Kommando-Zeile mit irgendwie Z-Shale und Pipapo. Und dann konnte man irgendwie mit diesem DOS auch so halbwegs arbeiten.
Das ging.
Aber nur dann. Also normal DOS, das hab ich ja vorher auch gemacht, das geht nicht. Also das ist einfach...
Nein. Wenn ich jetzt mal ein vernünftiges Terminal hätte, dann könnte ich mich immer auf meiner VM einfach reinhacken, dann wäre das relativ okay schon alles. Also auf der VM läuft dann ein Debian drauf und damit kann man ja schon notdürftig was machen. Kann man auch mal ein Ping absetzen, obwohl Ping geht ja auch unter Windows. Aber ein Host geht nicht, also kann es ja keiner. Ich weiß, es gibt bestimmt auch Host-Namen vor Windows-Auflösen oder sowas.
Aber es ist halt einfach nicht flüssig. Man merkt, da steckt kein Konzept dahinter. Und bei Unix, das war halt einfach so, wie man diese Maschine einfach benutzt hat die ganze Zeit, wie man da irgendwie Workflows hergestellt hat. Und das war halt, weil du hast schon immer nur so nachgemacht.
Ich weiß nicht alle so rsync.exe. Das ist auch so ein ganz großer Spaß. Was ich noch lustig finde, ist nur so Detail am Rande. Ich hab dann auch so, kommt natürlich wahrscheinlich davon, wenn man von Mac kommt und vieles sucht, dann hab ich mal so eingegeben bei Google, ich wollte sowas wie Growl haben, also Growl for Windows. Und weißt, was man findet? Ein Programm namens Growl for Windows. Das ist exakt, das heißt wirklich Growl for Windows. Und das ist wie Growl auf Mac. Nur das Ganze für Windows, ja. Das ist auch ganz gut. Da hab ich mir dann so ein Twitter-Klient auch noch, weil ein vernünftiges Twitter-Klient für Windows, der ist dann allerdings super. Nee, der ist nicht... Ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt. Der macht nichts weiter als die ganze Zeit Growl-Notifications einblenden. Dann halt einfach. Und die lässt du dann 10 Sekunden stehen und die sehen dann auch so ein bisschen Twitter-mäßiger aus und können auch Twittpics anzeigen und so ein Scheißdreck. Und dann ist quasi einer in der Ecke meines Bildschirms, da tauchen immer Nachrichten auf, wenn gerade welche da sind und wenn die nicht da sind, dann ignorierst du halt. Das ist so ganz niedlich. Das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Aber ansonsten ist das... Und es gibt auch... Irgendjemand hat auch ein Textmade für Windows geschrieben. Und das wird dann auch... Der heißt E, glaube ich. Und der wird auch beworben mit We Textmade für Windows.
Also wie... So wie Text... Wie Textmade plus Windows.
Genau. Also ein kompletter Clone. Die werben auch damit, dass sie...
Na, dann gibt's da DOS-Suffer für Windows.
Ja, da gibt's... Aber es ist echt lustig, dass es offensichtlich mittlerweile auch so ein Schritt... Genau. The Power of Textmade on Windows.
Wir sind jetzt auch wie Mac, sozusagen. Interessant. Ja, diese Desktop-Geschichte. Google sagt ja, Desktops sind eh bald überflüssig. Haben die gesagt. Ich weiß natürlich gerade wieder nicht, wer das gesagt hat, aber es war so ein Statement aus dem Google-Universum, wo sie meinten, wenn sie sich das Verhalten anschauen, wie so gesucht wird. Vor allem in Japan. Japan ist für sie wahrscheinlich so die Definition von Zukunft. Weil da ja so mobiles Leben schon immer ganz vorne stand. Die haben schon immer irgendwie mit ihren abgefahrenen Handys alles Mögliche getan, eben auch gesucht. Und das wäre halt einfach schon so die Mehrheit. Da ja an, wenn die Desktops im Internet eine Minderheit darstellen.
Ich halte es mittlerweile sogar für glaubwürdig. Zumindest was das private Surfen angeht. Also wenn wir uns jetzt irgendwie Ende April unsere iPads holen, wofür braucht man dann auch den Desktop-Rechner? Außer zum Arbeiten. Also wirklich Arbeiten, Arbeiten.
Also ich würde mich jetzt zwar nicht anschließen und sagen, in drei Jahren verschwinden die Desktop-Systeme von diesem Planeten. Die werden uns noch lange erhalten bleiben.
Natürlich.
Die Frage ist ja, was ist das, was irgendwie wirklich definiert, wie es weitergeht? Und ich denke, da ist es jetzt schon relativ absehbar, dass die Innovation findet im Mobilen statt. Irgendwo kann man das halt besser sehen als bei Apple, aber natürlich sind auch alle anderen irgendwie mit dabei. Dementsprechend ist der Krieg in diesem mobilen Bereich auch heiß, wie es so den Anschein hat. Und das haben wir ja gesehen.
Eine Überleitung, eine Überleitung.
An dieser ganzen Patentgeschichte, die jetzt irgendwie losfliegt. Wir haben ja schon ein paar Mal darüber geredet, aber es hat jetzt halt einfach eine neue Eskalationsstufe bekommen.
Jetzt prügelt sich ausnahmsweise mal Apple. Jetzt muss wir nochmal, jetzt prügeln. Diesmal ist es Apple, die zuerst zuschlagen.
Wie solltest du aufzureden, wenn ich mein Mikrofon ausschalte?
Ich wollte einfach gucken, was passiert.
Ich dachte, ich muss niesen, aber wenn du aufhörst zu reden, dann kann ich nicht niesen.
Ah, okay, dann niesen wir in aller Ruhe. Das Nokia hat Apple verklagt und so, daran haben wir uns ja mittlerweile gewöhnt, aber diesmal klagt ausnahmsweise auch mal Apple wieder.
Genau. Und jetzt fallen alle aus den Bäumen und Apple ist evil und überhaupt, und das geht ja nun gar nicht. Und das ist natürlich schon interessant, weil sie ja, also sie haben eine Klage angestrengt, eine Patentklage mit angeblich 20 Patenten, von denen irgendwie nur über 10 geredet wird. Das hab ich noch nicht so ganz begriffen. Auf jeden Fall ist da eine ganze Reihe von User-Interface-related Zeug mit drin.
Und wie verklagen sie?
Und sie verklagen HTC. Den Hersteller, einen der größten Hersteller von Handsets überhaupt. Und eben denjenigen, der auch am sichtbarsten eigentlich derzeit ist in der ganzen Debatte, um sowohl Zukunft von Windows Mobile als eben auch Android. Das Nexus One ist von HTC. Und...
Also HTC ist Google's Hardware-Produzent sozusagen?
Genau. Also einer von Google's Hardware-Produzenten.
Und hast du die Patente mal durch... Also ich hab mal die überhaupt nicht durchgelesen. Hast du die mal ein bisschen angelesen?
Ich hab so überflogen, worum es im Wesentlichen geht. Und da sind halt schon so diese klassischen Banal-Patente dabei, wie anlocke ich mein Telefon. Also dieses Sliden von links nach rechts, das ist halt etwas, wo Apple ein Patent drauf hält.
Wo man aber sagen könnte, Moment mal, das ist doch gar nicht HTC, das ist doch in dem Android-Betriebssystem schon drin. Warum verklagen die eigentlich nicht direkt Google?
Naja, weil sie... also erstmal, sie gehen halt gegen den Hersteller vor. Und Google zu verklagen, wäre glaube ich, auch ein bisschen pointless, weil es handelt sich dabei ja nicht um ein konkretes Produkt, was die haben, sondern Google stellt nur eine Software her und gibt sie im Internet frei zur Verfügung, dass man sie halt auf ihre Telefone machen kann.
Na, eine Software, die gegen Apples Patente verstößt.
Ja, so könnte man natürlich argumentieren, aber in dem Moment, wo sie auch kein Geld dafür nehmen, ist es wahrscheinlich einfach eine ganz andere Geschichte. Andererseits, denke ich, haben sie auch ein Interesse daran, nicht unmittelbar gegen Google vorzugehen, beziehungsweise sehen auch einen strategischen Vorteil darin, gegen HTC vorzugehen, weil wenn sie gegen HTC vorgehen, ist das im Prinzip auch ein Schuss vor den Bug von allen anderen Hardware-Herstellern, die potenziell eben überlegen, gegen Android vorzugehen. Sie müssten sozusagen damit rechnen, dass sich auch Apple explizit an sie wendet.
Die, die in Android einsetzen wollen, meinst du?
Genau. Und es geht ja auch, glaube ich, nicht nur um Android. Sondern es geht Apple generell um. Ah, ihr wollt Telefone bauen, die so sind wie unseres? Jetzt kann man natürlich verschiedene Aspekte dieser ganzen Sache beleuchten. Und natürlich muss man erstmal hinterfragen, was so die generelle Realität und Zulässigkeit von solchen Patenten betrifft. Ich meine, Software-Patente sind nun mal erstmal ein amerikanisches Ding.
Zum Glück.
Andererseits betrifft uns das auch. Klar. Nicht zuletzt, weil einfach die wesentliche Softwareentwicklung auf diesem Planeten nun mal in den USA stattfindet. Wir finden, denke ich, sind wir uns einig, dass wir generell eigentlich der Meinung sind, dass Software-Patente eine scheiß Idee sind. Weil es bringt einfach nur Ärger. Und John Gruber hat so einen schönen Punkt gebracht. Hätte damals Apple sein GUI im selben Maße patentieren lassen, also das von dem Original Mac OS, wie sie das jetzt mit ihrem iPhone-GUI machen, hätte es dann einen Next-Step überhaupt geben können? Hätte Steve Jobs, nachdem er von Apple weggegangen ist, überhaupt ein OS mit Maus und Icons und so weiter entwickeln können? Genau, vermutlich nicht. Das wirft natürlich schon echt eine interessante Frage auf. Andererseits muss man natürlich jetzt den aktuellen Patentkrieg, gut, da kann man jetzt über Softwarepatente generell wettern, nur ist es halt so, die anderen haben dasselbe Mittel auch zur Verfügung und offensichtlich bringen sie es ja auch zur Anwendung. Und an der Stelle ist natürlich Apple einfach mit der Frage konfrontiert, wie stehen wir innerhalb dieser Realität da? Benutzen wir jetzt diese Patente nur, um eine mögliche Verteidigungsposition einzunehmen, wie das eben vor kurzem noch bei Nokia war? Oder besteht diese Verteidigung nicht vielleicht eben auch aus den FintUSA ohnehin populär gewordenen Preemptive Strike?
Na ja, und wie ist denn das? War da das Multitouch-Patent mit dabei, bei den Angemahnten?
Soweit ich das gesehen habe, war dem nicht so. Sondern es handelte sich eigentlich primär. Ich werd jetzt nochmal kurz diese Liste hier hochholen.
Bei diesem Multitouch, da war doch so, dass Android-Geräte in Europa einen Multitouch im Browser hatten. In Amerika aber nicht. Da war das ja im Browser nicht vorhanden.
Meint wer hat das nicht?
Wenn du einen Motorola-Droid in Amerika gekauft hast, dann hat das keinen Multitouch im Browser. Wenn du hier das deutsche Pontau holst, hat das Multitouch. Genau, das ist auch bei den HTC-Geräten so. Und ich glaube auch beim Nexus One. Und dann hat Google irgendwann gesagt, dann kam ein Update raus für Android, und plötzlich konnten auch die amerikanischen Geräte alle Multitouch. Und wenn dann jetzt das Multitouch bei diesen Patenten mit dabei gewesen wäre, dann hätten wir sagen müssen, Moment mal, verklagt jetzt nicht den falschen?
Also ich finde es generell eigentlich nicht schön, dass solche Kriege ausgefochten werden. Ich meine, es ist natürlich schon so, alle versuchen weitgehend jetzt eigentlich, das nachzubauen, was das iPhone erfolgreich macht. Das liegt natürlich komplett auf der Hand. Andererseits kann man auch argumentieren, gut, da ist das dann halt, wenn man irgendwie eine Idee in die Welt gesetzt hat und konkret in ein Produkt umsetzt, dann ist sie halt da. Und dann kann sie eben auch kopiert werden. Gut, die amerikanische Gesetzgebung ist da halt einfach jetzt anders drauf.
Weil die europäisch ja im Wesentlichen auch.
Genau, Patente gibt es hier auch und es gibt auch viel, was in diese Richtung von Patentierung von Vorgängen und so weiter geht. Hier wird es dann halt anders deklariert. Hier macht man dann immer eine Maschine draus und dann ist es auch schon wieder so ein Ding. Also man kann es nicht so abstrakt als Algorithmus beschreiben, sondern man beschreibt es dann halt als irgendwie etwas, wo man die Algorithmus eingebaut hat und das ist irgendwie so eine Maschine und da darf halt keiner auch so eine Maschine bauen, die eben genau so was tut. Von daher ist es natürlich auch dasselbe Problem.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall sind jetzt... Ist das jetzt schon der offene Krieg zwischen... Ist noch nicht der offene Krieg. Ist jetzt der kalte Krieg zwischen Google und Apple eigentlich, oder?
Naja, dieser Krieg, der geht ja sowieso in der ganzen Branche ab, also ich hab da so ein schönes Übersichtsgrafik gesehen, wer denn alles so, wem denn da schon in den letzten Wochen und Monaten verklagt hat. Das ist also ein fröhliches Schneeballwerfen, was da gerade stattfindet. Alle schmeißen halt irgendwie an, die Frage ist halt nur, wer hat mehr Schneeballer als der andere, also es ist der totale Krieg. Das passt natürlich schön in dieses Bild vorher, so mit der Desktop spielt irgendwie keine große Rolle mehr. Das scheint sich dann doch langsam durchzusetzen und im Prinzip ist das ja jetzt eine, wie soll ich sagen, es ist ja geradezu Goldgräber-Stimmung, weil jetzt wirst du mich gleich wieder hauen, aber Windows hat seine Dominanz auf dem Desktop, aber im Mobilbereich sind sie halt einfach eine kleine Nummer bis hin zu, also ich halte es sogar für möglich, dass sie überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielen. Also nicht nur eine untergeordnete, sondern alles was sie tun, bringt sie so dermaßen aus der Bahn und auch dieses Windows Phone 7, da sehe ich jetzt noch überhaupt keinerlei Grund, warum das jetzt irgendwie erfolgreicher sein sollte, als die anderen, weil ich nämlich einfach ihr ganzes Business-Modell in Frage stelle. Also dieses Prinzip mit wir bauen ein Betriebssystem und ihr zahlt uns dafür Geld, dass wir das auf eure Computer drauf bauen, auf eure Telefone.
Dass ihr das selber installieren dürft?
Ja, das wird von Android so dermaßen ausgehebelt, dass ich einfach nicht glaube, dass für Microsoft da noch irgendwie nennenswert Geld zu holen ist.
Daraus, dass sie sind richtig gut. Aber das sind Zündmaugliche.
Ja, aber ich glaube sogar, wenn sie echt verdammt richtig gut wären, wäre es sehr schwierig, extrem viel besser zu sein als Android.
Also ich glaube, wenn Apple jetzt genau diese Politik fahren würde mit dem iPhone, und das zum Beispiel HTC lizenzieren würde, nehmen wir sie an. Gar keine Frage, dass das nicht passieren wird. Aber ich glaube HTC würde ohne mit der Wimper zu zocken, 10 Dollar pro Gerät zahlen, um iPhone US auf ihren Geräten drauf zu haben. Also ich glaube, dass dieses Geschäftsmodell schon nach wie vor funktionieren könnte, auch in Zeiten von Open Source.
Ne, das glaube ich eben nicht, weil Apple tut es ja nicht. Und warum tut es Apple nicht? Weil sie so gut sind, dass sie blöd werden, warum sie nicht die Hardware gleich selber mitverkaufen, weil damit verdienen sie Geld. Warum sollen sie irgendwie 10 Dollar pro Gerät verdienen, wenn sie auch 150 Dollar verdienen können? Oder wie viel machen sie? Sie machen irgendwie 30 Prozent auf irgendwie 600, wie auch immer, 200, you name it. Auf jeden Fall ein vielfaches Zunehmen, was in irgendeiner Form mit Lizenzierung reinzuholen ist. Die selbe Erfahrung haben sie ja auch schon gemacht, als sie da mal irgendwie überlegt haben, Mac OS zu lizenzieren. Wozu hat das geführt? Power Computing und so weiter kamen an, haben irgendwie billige Klons gemacht. Und es war halt in jeder Hinsicht für sie schlecht. Erstens haben sie mit jedem Computer, in dem er anders verkauft hat, ex orbitant viel weniger Geld eingenommen. Zweitens haben sie die Kontrolle über ihre Plattform verloren, weil sie sie nicht beliebig weiterentwickeln konnten. Und drittens war auf einmal alles definiert von Schiepo-Scheiße. Auf einmal war irgendwie billig das Gute. Das war einfach vernichtend eigentlich für die Macintosh-Plattform. Und es war sehr, sehr, sehr klug von ihnen, dass sie das eben dann sofort haben wieder sein lassen. Das war ja das erste, was Steve Jobs dann auch weggeaxed hat. Von daher ist das eine super hypothetische Geschichte, zu sagen, was wäre, wenn und dann würde da HTC das machen.
Also ich glaube, dieses Geschäftsmodell könnte funktionieren. Das hat jetzt nicht zwangsläufig damit zu tun, dass Android das wegaxed. Also wenn Microsoft jetzt ein wirklich verdammt gutes Betriebssystem hätte, dann könnten sie dieses Geschäftsmodell, glaube ich, fahren und damit auch gutes Geld verdienen.
Ja, aber das ein Problem ist, dass die Firmen einfach Microsoft an der Stelle auch überhaupt nicht mehr vertrauen. Weil mit wem auch immer Microsoft in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren ins Bett gegangen ist, sie haben alle darunter gelitten. Wer hat denn bitteschön mit Microsoft Erfolg gehabt? Keiner.
Dell. Dell.
Ja, und wie geht es ihnen jetzt gerade so irgendwie?
Na ja, schlecht fürs, glaube ich, der falsche Ausdruck.
Ja, aber sie haben keine Möglichkeit, sich an dem Markt in irgendeiner Form selbst neu zu definieren, weil sie eben kein OS in der Hand haben, weil sie keinerlei Differenzierungsmöglichkeiten haben.
Nee, wäre ich dazu auch technisch nicht...
Nee, Moment. Und sie haben auch Verträge mit Microsoft, die im Prinzip besagen, wenn du hier Microsoft verkaufen willst, dann darfst du auch mit gar keinem anderen OS irgendwie werben.
Ja, aber... Nebelverträge. Ja, klar, das ist das eine, aber man muss auch einfach sagen, Dell ist auch einfach eine Firma, die ist total uninnovativ. Also ich meine, kannste dich noch dunkel dran erinnern, als sie mal ihren eigenen MP3-Player rausgebracht haben? Das war wirklich so... Also da gab's den iPod schon, da gab's alle schon...
Ja, weil sie nämlich, da kommen wir nämlich zu einem interessanten Punkt, weil sie keine eigene Softwareentwicklung haben. Früher war das mal so, früher im Sinne von in den 70ern und auch noch in den 80ern, da war die gesamte Computerwelt davon beseelt, dass alle irgendwie ihre Systeme hatten. Alle hatten irgendwie ihre Hardware, hatten ihre Software, da gab's den Amiga, da gab's Atari, Apple gab es und alle hatten irgendwie ihre Systeme und standen sozusagen in vollständiger Konkurrenz zu einer. Und dann wurde das auf einmal en vogue zu sagen, naja, das ist ja das Auslaufmodell, weil jetzt kommt ja irgendwie Microsoft und die Software verkauft sich unabhängig von der Hardware und wunderbar.
Hat ja auch gut funktioniert, muss man sagen.
Hat für sie ganz gut funktioniert, aber es hat eben auch mit Businessmethoden funktioniert, die einfach schon nicht mehr als lauter gelten können.
Das hat für Microsoft gut funktioniert, aber es hat auch für Hersteller, die nie die Innovationspotenzial hatten. Also ich meine, Dell muss ja, was sie im Endeffekt machen mussten, ist ja auf dem Markt Teile einzukaufen und die zusammenzuschrauben und dabei bessere Verträge auszuhandeln als beim Einkauf, als die anderen und darüber das Ganze billig zu machen.
Ja, aber es gab keinerlei nennenswerte Unterscheidungsfähigkeiten. Und in dem Moment, wo halt dieses Modell Desktop-Computer mit Bürosoftware drauf jetzt nicht mehr das einzige ist, mit dem man irgendwie das große Geld macht, jetzt merkt man auf einmal, oh, jetzt kommt es dann auf einmal doch wieder auf die Hardware an. Und jetzt reicht es mal nicht, irgendeine Generic-Software auf eine Generic-Hardware zu werfen, weil es nämlich den Anforderungen auf einmal nicht mehr gerecht wird.
Ich finde es ja auch krass, wie gesagt, das ist dieses Trackpad-Link, was mir so extrem aufgefallen ist, dass Apple ja durchaus auch bei dem einzigen Differenzierungspunkt, den Dell zum Beispiel hätte von einem anderen Hersteller, nämlich eine geile Tastatur, ein tolles Trackpad dazu zu liefern, wirklich schönes Gerät zu bauen, auch da wären sie wirklich von Apple ausgestochen. Dieses Glass-Trackpad, das ist nichts. Ich habe Amazon durchwühlt. Es ist nichts da draußen käuflich erwerbbar, was dem auch nur nahekommt. Das ist echt krass. Das ist nur nichts dramatisches. Da hätten auch andere drauf kommen können, wenn sie sich mal ein bisschen hingesetzt haben und sagen, wozu, wo können wir uns jetzt von der Konkurrenz ein bisschen abheben? Durch ein besseres Trackpad. Das liegt eigentlich fast auf der Hand.
Ja, und generell auch durch bessere Hardware. Es ist immer der Punkt, wo die Hardware nur dann besser wird, wenn sie dann von der Software besser integriert wird. Das wäre genau wieder bei diesem System-Ding. Jetzt waren wir aber bei diesen Patenten. Ich hatte ja gesagt, jetzt gibt es auf einmal so eine neue Goldgräber-Stimmung. Hab jetzt ein bisschen weit ausgeholt. Wo ich hinaus wollte, ist, es gibt jetzt auf einmal wieder einen Markt zu besetzen. Ein Markt, den es vorher so überhaupt nicht mehr gab. Microsoft hat mit seiner Megadominanz und seinen Knebelverträgen irgendwie jede Competition komplett außen vor gehalten. Und sie haben lange Zeit geglaubt, dass ihnen das mit Windows Mobile auch gelingen wird. Dass sie quasi selbstverständlich sagen, wir liefern jetzt auch noch die Software hier und jetzt kommt ihr wieder mit eurem ganzen Chipo, PDA und Telefonscheiß an und wir flößen da unseren kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner drauf. Und alles ist gut.
Auch da hat es ja, muss man sagen, lange okay funktioniert. Ich meine, bevor Apple den Markt betreten hat, gab es da Pallen, die noch ein bisschen rumgekränkelt haben, aber auch schon Windows Mobile installiert haben. Aber ansonsten hatte man da genau die gleiche Windows-Mobile-Welt, wie auf dem Test-Card.
Es war aber nicht so, dass sie da den selben Marktanteil gehabt hätten.
Stimmt, ja, da gab es immer noch Rimmen.
Nicht im Ansatz, ja. Ich kenne die Zahlen über die Jahre so nicht, aber ich bezweifle, dass sie nennenswert über 20% hinausgekommen sind. Da gab es immer auch Nokia und da gab es auch immer alle anderen. Und das war halt einfach mal nicht Windows Mobile. So war es nicht. Jetzt kann man natürlich losgehen und sagen, ok, ja, aber die Business PDAs mit Stift in der und der Größe und dann haben sie einen größeren Anteil gehabt und so weiter. Wir sehen jetzt da eben eine Konvergenz. Und auf einmal wird allen klar, oh weia, es werden in wenigen Jahren mehr Leute und zwar exorbitant viel mehr Leute mit Mobile Devices im Internet ihre primäre Kommunikation betreiben. Das ist das, worauf ich hinaus will. Das wird sozusagen das wichtigste Kommunikationsgerät wird das mobile Gerät und der Desktop-Computer wird in zunehmendem Maße und das schließt die Laptops mit ein, wird eine Nische in Anführungsstrichen eine extrem große Nische noch so, aber es ist schon so die Nische der Leute, die halt anspruchsvoll Dinge erzeugen. Creators, Fotografen, Grafiker, Videomenschen, Leute, die massiv mit Text arbeiten, Layout machen, wo du Platz brauchst, wo du Tastatur brauchst, wo du alles Premiere brauchst, wo du bereit bist, deinem Gerät viel Raum einzuräumen und wo das irgendwie wichtig ist. Das hat irgendwie 50% deines Schreibtischs und kann alle möglichen Ein- und Ausgänge und Interfaces und Schnittstellen und Erweiterungen und so weiter. Das ist das.
Ich glaube, damit bist du schon fast... Ich glaube, die Gruppe wird noch kleiner sein, derjenige, die einen Desktop brauchen.
Ja gut, aber wie auch immer, sie wird auch tendenziell eher kleiner, während jetzt mit dem iPad und dem iPhone und mit allen anderen mobilen Devices, auch den ganzen Android-Geräten, die jetzt in die gleiche Bresche schlagen, ein neuer Markt aufgemacht wird, eben dieses Mobile-Computing, was einerseits durch seine Mobilität besticht, aber das ist nur der Grund, warum die Leute das haben wollen, aber eben auch ganz neue Interfaces bietet und das ganze Computing auch einfacher macht. Das ist das große Versprechen. Und ich denke, mit dem iPad werden wir da auch nochmal einen neuen Schub sehen, dass hier sozusagen Computer weniger Computer sein werden. Man nimmt sie mehr als Device wahr, was eine bestimmte Aufgabe erfüllt und weniger so ein generischer Computer, mit dem ich alle möglichen Aufgaben machen kann.
Das finde ich ganz interessant, dass ich auf Arbeit mit einem PC arbeite, das ist ja auch so ein Experiment. Das geht ja auch durchaus in die Richtung, wenn dann das iPad kommt, dann will ich es mir holen. Und morgens in der U-Bahn, wo ich zum Beispiel mit dem iPhone da sitze, um meine News zu lesen, wäre ich in Zukunft wahrscheinlich mit dem iPad sitzen. Das heißt, ich werde wahrscheinlich auch in Zukunft mit einem größeren mobilen Gerät rumrennen, um mein Computingzeug zu machen. Aber ich sehe kommen, oder ich bin mal gespannt, ob das quasi das Versprechen einlösen kann, was die Netbooks eigentlich einlösen wollten damals. Das ist der kleine Rechner, den ich den ganzen Tag mit mir rumschleppe, weil ich die massive Rechenpower und die Möglichkeiten, die in meinem MacBook stecken, tagsüber feststelle, gar nicht mehr brauche. Das ist das Exponent, was ich gerade mache. Ich glaube, das wird tatsächlich sehr stark in die Richtung gehen. Man braucht es einfach nicht die ganze Zeit über.
Und deswegen ist es eine Goldgräberstimmung. Weil auf einmal kommen die ganzen Firmen stellen fest, der Markt teilt sich komplett neu auf. Das, was bisher der Computermarkt war, waren einfach Desktops. Plus die mobile Variante des Desktops, der Laptop. Was aber im Wesentlichen dasselbe ist, bloß zum Zusammenklappen. Und da war Microsoft stark. Die Einzigen, die in der Lage waren, da nennenswert einen Marktanteil überhaupt zu erheischen, was ja eigentlich lange Zeit schon keiner mehr für Möglichkeiten hat, war Apple. Je nachdem, welchen Zahlen man jetzt glauben mag, irgendwie einen weltweiten Anteil von 5 bis 10 Prozent haben. Aber jedes 0,1 Prozent, was sie weltweit einen Marktanteil gut machen, bringt ihnen exorbitant viel Geld ein durch ihre Supermargen, dass sie zu dem Margen Großverdiener schlechthin geworden sind. Also dass sie irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was war da die Zahl, dass sie irgendwie 20 Prozent eigentlich allen ausgegebenen Geld für Computer bei Apple hatten.
Zumindest Amerika?
Nein, es waren 10 Prozent.
Aber bei Rechnern mit über 1000 Dollar haben sie einen Marktanteil von 90 Prozent?
Ja gut, aber da kannst du die Grenzen natürlich beliebig setzen. Wie ist es mit Computern über 850 Dollar? Wie sieht es da aus? Das ist so eine komische Zahl. Ich meine 1000 Dollar, okay, gut.
Na ja, es ist aber der Bereich, in dem Apple überhaupt erst anfängt eigentlich.
Ich würde sagen, bei 1500 Dollar haben sie vielleicht sogar 100 Prozent. Aber wie viel Geld ist das letzten Endes? Also die Zahl, fand ich auch sehr interessant, aber die hätte ich ganz gerne mal als eine Kurve gesehen. Also wenn man jetzt mal runtergeht, bei 900, bei 800, also wo ist da so der Bruch? Weil irgendwo nehmen sie nicht mehr 90 Prozent ein. Und die Zahl haben sie so nicht genannt.
Aber ich finde es ganz spannend, dass sie eigentlich in dem Bereich, wo sie eigentlich nur aktiv sind, nämlich mit Rechnen über 1000 Dollar, weil kostet das kleinste MacBook unter 1000 Dollar?
Ja.
Ganz knapp, oder? So 950. Also dass ab dem Bereich, wo sie eigentlich erst aktiv werden, plötzlich einen gigantischen Marktanteil haben.
Ja, genau. Das ist das Erstaunliche. Und offensichtlich sind sie nämlich jetzt...
Sie wären sich ihren Markt doch so ausgesucht, haben gar keine Frage. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie plötzlich in den 500-Dollar-Markt gehen könnten und da genauso viel hätten.
Apple ist nur in einem Markt, wo man Geld verdienen kann. Das ist, wo man mit hohen Margen arbeiten kann. Das ist auch das, was viele Leute eben nicht verstehen. Warum auch dieser weltweite Anteil am Gesamtmarkt eigentlich auch Borus ist, den zu betrachten. Weil so würde ja auch bei Autos keiner rechnen. Also ist ja schon interessant, ob du Kleinwagen oder Lastwagen machst, ob du irgendwie Unimogs baust für Spezialanwendungen oder halt so generische Familientransporter.
Na ja, wenn du Software dafür entwickelst, ist es dir eigentlich prinzipiell wurscht, ob die jetzt gekauft wird für einen 500 Dollar Rechner oder für einen 2000 Dollar Rechner. Hauptsache, ich verkaufe Masse.
Ja gut, aber als Entwickler bist du natürlich auch interessiert, was für eine...
Wie zahlungskräftig ist die?
Genau, wie zahlungskräftig und bereit ist die. Und das ist ja auch so ein Ding, dass du auf dem Macintosh-Markt eigentlich als Entwickler sehr viel mehr von deinen Kunden erwarten kannst als auf anderen Plattformen. Bei Windows ist es halt so, dass eben ganz viele Leute, die das eben einsetzen, überhaupt gar keine potenziellen Kunden sind, weil das einfach bei irgendwelchen Firmen steht und von daher kannst du wahrscheinlich von diesen X-Millionen, die das angeblich sind, einfach auch schon mal einen hohen Betrag komplett abziehen. Na ja, ausser du verkaufst Firmen als Kunden. Ja, richtig, aber dann hast du halt eine Firma, so okay, so wollte ich es nicht rechnen. Klar, natürlich. Außer du verkaufst aber auch da ist der Markt dann halt einfach segmentiert und man kann nicht generell sagen, dass jeder verkaufte Windows-Rechner für dich ein potenzieller Markt ist. Das ist halt einfach nicht so. Beim Macintosh ist das natürlich auch nicht so, aber es ist schon sehr viel homogener. Gar keine Frage. Und die Leute sind bereit, mehr Geld dafür zu bezahlen. Zurück jetzt nochmal zu dieser Goldgräber-Stimmung. Also alle stürzen, die sich jetzt irgendwie drauf und sehen, okay, mobile, die Karten werden neu gemischt. Es kann sehr wohl sein, dass das, was heute alle Computer sind, eigentlich nur noch eine kleine Nische ist und dass der Mobile-Markt ganz wichtig wird. Und jetzt kommen sie alle an und wollen mitspielen. Nokia möchte ganz gerne der Platzhörsch bleiben. Das wird ihnen, wie ich schon häufiger hier orakelt habe, meiner Meinung nach nicht gelingen. So, auch wenn sie da jetzt noch in diesem spezifischen Segment Smartphones recht groß sind. Aber Apple hat ja auch schon die große Keule ausgepackt, als sie meinten, wir sind ja eigentlich jetzt die Mobile-Company Nummer 1. Weil wir ja auch unsere Laptops verkaufen. Da dachte ich auch so am ersten Moment so... Ja, groß drauf. Dann fiel mir aber auf, dass ja, ich weiß gar nicht, was daraus geworden ist, aber Nokia hat ja auch vor kurzem ein Netbook angekündigt. Ist da eigentlich irgendwas daraus geworden?
Ich glaube, das kann man sich kaufen.
Kann man sich irgendwie kaufen. Also jetzt sozusagen zu argumentieren, mobile sind nur Telefone, das stimmt so auch nicht. Man kann schon sagen, dass ein MacBook auch gegen ein Netbook ankämpft. Ich denke, mobil wird es in dem Moment, wo man es in die Tasche packen kann. Insofern haben sie da auch total recht. So, und wer kann jetzt gewinnen? Gewinnen können eigentlich nur diejenigen, die in der Lage sind, komplette Systeme zu bauen, die in der Lage sind, Hardware und Software wunderbar aufeinander abzustimmen. Das sagt Apple schon immer von seinen Systemen und es ist auf Skepsis gestoßen. Und jetzt sehen wir halt mit solchen Sachen wie dem iPad, ja, ist jetzt mal wieder brüchiges Eis, weil dieses Gerät kommt ja erst in vier Wochen, aber mehrfach wurde bekräftigt, das Teil hält irgendwie zehn Stunden durch. Das heißt, da ist halt auch geschafft worden, dass Stromverbrauch gesenkt wird, bei so einem großen Display, dass das Ding einfach irgendwie lange läuft. Das ist schon sehr wichtig und das kann man eben einfach nur durch gute Integration erreichen. So, viel geredet.
Viel geredet.
Also ja, ich weiß, was Sie jetzt sagen wollen. Sie haben recht.
Also ich sehe es ein bisschen schon so, dass... Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Zum einen dieses Gefühl, dass man sich mehr und mehr wie ein Borg fühlt, wenn man morgens in der U-Bahn steht und... Ich sage mal wieder U-Bahn, ich bin jetzt sehr U-Bahn fixiert plötzlich. Ich stehe morgens in der U-Bahn und jeder Dritte hat ein iPhone.
Gefühlt hat jeder Dritte ein iPhone. Jeder Dritte, der überhaupt irgendwas in der Hand hat, hat ein iPhone.
Wenn du was in der Hand hältst, dann ist es ein iPhone. Und mit ziemlicher Sicherheit. Und wenn du Kopfhörer aufhast, dann sind das mit ziemlicher Sicherheit weiße Kopfhörer.
Und die, die keinen Kopfhörer aufhaben und nichts in der Hand haben?
Das sind... Ich glaube, die sind einfach tot und... Die liegen da seit Monaten in der U-Bahn rum und es ist ja auch niemand aufgefallen.
Messendeko.
Das ist einfach nur, um die Bahn vollzukriegen. Ja, also wenn die Leute morgens ihr Telefon draußen haben, dann ist es wirklich mit ziemlicher Sicherheit ein iPhone. Und ich würd's schöner finden, wenn das ausdifferenzierter ist. Wenn da mehr verschiedene Geräte sind. Also eine Zeit lang, auch wenn man in einem Café sitzt, hat man ja, wo viele Leute mit Rechner sitzen, was weiß ich jetzt, Oberholz oder sowas.
Ach, jetzt kommt schon wieder die Angst vor Apple wird alles dominieren.
Nein, das heißt, das wird dominieren. Das ist einfach für mich als persönliches Ausdruck. Also ich mein, bis vor ein paar Jahren war's ja auch als Apple-User noch der totale Exot, aha, ein Apple. Und wenn du jetzt irgendwo hinkommst, aha, ein Apple.
Na, wir wollen ja auch Exoten sein, oder?
Ja, eben, es sind aber...
Ach, das stört dich jetzt.
Wir sind es nicht mehr, wir sind keine Exoten mehr. Wir sind ja total im Mainstream geworden.
Von der Kunst in der Elite noch zur Elite zu gehören. Ich find das nicht so schlimm, ja. Also ich find das irgendwie... Okay, mich hätte das ehrlich gesagt extrem verstört, wenn das jetzt nicht passiert wäre.
Mir wird's gerade ein bisschen... Also ich muss jetzt nicht unbedingt Windows-Phones sein, aber wenn ein paar mehr Leute auch ein Android haben und sowas, find ich das schon schick.
Naja, ein paar Leute haben ja auch Android. Vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt in der Berliner U-Bahn, aber es ist auch nicht so, dass es das nicht geben wird. Und andere Märkte, andere Sitten, vielleicht ist es hier bei uns jetzt so in der westlichen Welt einfach mal so und woanders ist es nicht unmittelbar so. Wobei ich nach wie vor da so bei meinem Android... Also ich hab da ja mal eine Zweifel.
Die hab ich mittlerweile auch wieder. Und zwar ich hab meiner Freundin mein Android aufgedrückt. Also sie war irgendwie bei mir, ihr Handy, Akku war alle und ich hatte ja schon vor Ewigkeit mal vorgeschlagen, nimm doch einfach das Android, das liegt hier rum und ich nutze es kaum. Und die hat so einen total alten Knochen mit Sony RX und will sich jetzt seit Ewigkeiten schon ein iPhone kaufen, aber wie das halt so ist, kommt halt nicht dazu und Vertrag läuft noch ewig und sowas. Und dann hab ich gesagt, nimm doch einfach das Android und probier das mal aus, ob du damit klarkommst und dann hab ich ihr das alles ein bisschen eingerichtet, haben wir ihre SIM-Karte reingesteckt und es funktioniert auch alles, aber sie ist... Was für ein Telefon? Mein altes HTC Magic. Das hab ich mir damals gekauft. Und es ist schon, also es mag jetzt sein, dass das mit Android 2.0 und 2.1 deutlich besser geworden ist. Die hab ich ja beide leider nicht auf dem Ding, weil es ja noch nicht geht, aber dieses Android 1.6, was da drauf ist, das ist schon von Geeks gemacht und nicht von, also so von, das ist, es fängt schon damit an, es ist, bei den standardmäßigen Klingeltönen ist kein schöner Klingelton dabei. Bei Apple, das sind, also da ist, man kann nicht mal einen eigenen SMS-Ton hochspielen, aber die sind schon okay, die Sachen, die dabei sind. Da hat sich ein Sounddesigner angesetzt. Bei den Klingeltönen, bei den Wecker-Klingeltönen, die du auf diesem Android dabei hast, da ist ein Hahn, der furchtbar klingt, da ist so der klassische Klingelingelingwecker, der furchtbar klingt, da sind ein Haufen schlecht klingender Klingeltöne dabei. Und natürlich, wenn du das Ding in die Hand nimmst und dir das erstmal einrechtest, dann möchtest du auch gerne was Schönes, was Gefälliges dabei haben. Und so ist das an sehr, sehr vielen Punkten, wo einfach die Technik und die Software vielleicht stimmt, aber die Bedienung und die Icons und der Sound und dieses ganze Gesamterlebnis einfach total gebrochen wird wegen so absoluten Kleinigkeiten. Das ist so, und sie nutzt es jetzt, sie twittert damit wie bekloppt, oder was heißt wie bekloppt, sie twittert damit deutlich mehr als vorher und sie kann auch unterwegs chatten, aber sie sagt auch, ich mag das nicht, das funktioniert nicht so, wie es will und ich hab immer das Gefühl, bäh und weiße Teufel was.
So, haben wir jetzt jetzt durch hier mit unseren Patenten und so weiter, wir sind so ein bisschen...
Wie hatten wir das Thema Patente?
Wir hatten das Thema nicht Patente, aber ich finde das jetzt, sagen wir mal, im Einzelnen so gar nicht so diskussionswürdig. Klar, also wie gesagt, patente Scheiße. Man kann jetzt einfach nur feststellen, ok, alles klar, da ist jetzt der Patent-War ausgebrochen. Weil es einfach so ein heiß umkämpfter Markt ist und weil sie alle sehen, ok, die Karten im Computing-Business werden einfach komplett neu gemischt. Und Microsoft hat irgendwie keinen Hammer mehr in der Hand.
Im Augenblick gerade auf keinen Fall. Und es sieht tatsächlich auch nicht so aus, als ob sie demnächst einen hätten.
Genau, stattdessen hat man diesen permanent unter Drogen erwirkenden Balmer, der irgendwie dummes Zeug von sich gibt.
Der jetzt ja die Firma in die Cloud bewegen will.
Will er das?
Ja, hast du es nicht mitbekommen? Die soll jetzt in die Cloud gehen.
Microsoft komplett selber oder was? Ja, alles klar auf Cloud.
Microsoft will ja auch mal so gehostet oder was? Die fangen jetzt langsam an gegen Google-Apps zu prügeln. Ich glaube nämlich, dass sie langsam so Angst kriegen. Weil es gibt ja diese Google-Apps für... Ich hab jetzt so troppe Zeit.
Vielleicht... Jetzt will ich auch noch mal an einer anderen Hoffnung... Also das hab ich bei dir ja immer so rausgehört, immer so dieses... Ja, aber was wäre denn, wenn... Stell dir doch mal vor, Microsoft mit seiner ganzen Macht könnte auch tatsächlich mal was Tolles machen. Wie schön wäre das? Denke ich mir auch so, ja. Eigentlich wäre das ja mal echt toll. Als wir so über Bing geredet haben, klang das bei mir auch so ein bisschen an. Ein bisschen so ein eigener Brand und so. In den Kommentaren meinte dann jemand, na ja, sie werben schon auch irgendwie bei Microsoft. Aber es heißt halt nicht Microsoft Bing und es heißt auch nicht Microsoft Search. Sondern es heißt Bing. Und bei Microsoft ist es nicht so, dass sie jetzt komplett verschweigen, dass das von ihnen ist und was mit ihnen was zu tun hat. Aber gut, wie auch immer.
Kennst du dieses?
Ich wollte ja nur diese Hoffnung so mit Microsoft so. Ich bezweifle allerdings, oder ich hab zumindest so, ich hab einfach Zweifel, dass die Unternehmenskultur, die sich bei Microsoft herausgebildet hat, in irgendeiner Form wirklich nochmal so was hervorbringen kann. Es wird zwar immer wieder so einzelne Forschergruppen geben und so jetzt mit diesen Maps und so. Klar, das ist irgendwie alles ganz neat und hübsch, aber die arbeiten einfach nicht an einer Vision. Also sogar jetzt dieses, wenn sie das jetzt eingesehen hätten, dass ihr Mobilmarkt weggeht, warum sind sie dann da mit drei Plattformen gerade am Werkeln? Also je nachdem, wie man es zählt. Also es gibt jetzt dieses alte Windows-Mobile, das ist jetzt Version 6.5 gemacht, das nennen sie jetzt Classic. Dann haben sie gesagt, okay, alles klar, wir scheißen auf unsere Entwickler und werfen das ganze AP weg. Da kann man erst mal sagen, okay, hurra.
Das ist wenigstens konsequent.
Gut, aber ich denke auch nicht, dass sie irgendeine andere Chance gehabt haben, weil da wollte auch keiner mehr für entwickeln. Das ist einfach vorbei.
Ja, aber diesen Schritt muss man trotzdem bereit sein zu gehen.
Gut, wir auch immer so. Jetzt gehen sie aber, soweit ich informiert bin, ist dieses Windows Phone 7 derselbe Körner. Ja, das ist nicht so, dass sie da ein neues Betriebssystem haben. Es ist nur so, dass sie im Application Layer, also wie man da mit ruminterfässt, sich was Neues zusammenbauen.
Ich dachte, das wäre der Kernel von Xeon und das wäre so ein quasi Windows 7 Kernel.
Ich bin... Ich bin nicht...
Ich dachte, das wäre kein Windows 10 mehr.
Ich bin mir nicht... Es wäre mir wirklich neu, dass sie da was anderes haben. Es gibt so ein anderes Projekt irgendwie, dieses Pink-Projekt, was aus dieser Danger-Akkquisition herauskommt.
Und da wären jetzt ja wahrscheinlich demnächst irgendwelche Geräte auf dem Markt.
Wo sie neulich diesen Trouble hatten mit den gelöschten Daten, die sie im letzten Moment doch noch irgendwie an die Race bekommen haben. War knapp. Die halt auch irgendwie an irgendeinem mobilen Kern arbeiten. Aber das ist halt nochmal eine andere Division.
Ja, aber das...
Die arbeiten nicht an einer Vision, sondern die haben da zwei verschiedene Sachen. Also sie haben das alte und das neue Windows Mobile. Und sie haben irgendwie dieses Ping-Projekt. Und die arbeiten halt gegeneinander. Sprich, bei Microsoft gibt es einfach keinerlei Kultur, die in der Lage ist, das in geordnete Bahnen zu schicken. Und zu sagen, wir machen jetzt auch mal was wirklich Cooles.
Na, ich glaube, also das ist ja sowas, dieses internen Konkurrenzaufbau. Das ist ja durchaus auch... Also ich weiß, dass beim Metro es ja... Gibt es ja den Media Markt und Saturn zum Beispiel. Das sind ja auch zwei Konzerne, zwei Geschäftsketten, die im Wesentlichen dasselbe machen, aber trotzdem gegeneinander antreten und Konkurrenten sind, obwohl sie zum selben Konzern gehören.
Das sind keine Konkurrenten. Wenn du beim Media Markt was nicht findest, dann schicken die dich rüber zu Saturn und lächeln dabei.
Ja klar, aber die sind nach außen hin, also so auf der...
Tun die so als werden sie.
Nee, wenn es um Zahlen geht, auch im Konzern sind die schon Konkurrenten. Da sind zwei Firmen, die gegeneinander antreten. Egal, brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht uns über Saturn oder den Medienmarkt aufzuregen. Was ich glaube, was eigentlich noch viel dramatischer ist an den ganzen Problemen, ist... Und insofern finde ich das schon spannend, dass Microsoft hat ja nach wie vor nur zwei Abteilungen, mit denen sie Kohle machen. Und das ist die Windows-Abteilung und das ist die Office-Abteilung. Und ich glaube, so werden da auch, wenn die sich im Konzern irgendwie mal zusammensetzen zu einem großen Treffen, dann kommt da irgendwie so ein kleiner Windows-Mobile-Fuzzi und daneben sitzt dann jemand aus der Office-Abteilung. Dann kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die auch durchaus raushängen lassen, wer da die Kohle reinholt in den Laden und wer wirklich wichtig ist und wer die kleine Spiele-Abteilung hat, die eigentlich so, die kann man sich ja leisten.
Die lassen sich nicht nur raushängen, sondern die sagen halt, naja, Zusammenarbeit mit uns nutze unsere Bedingungen.
Ja, aber auch, dass die jetzt ihnen langsam offensichtlich der Gedanke kommt, wir müssen auch diese Office-Abteilung mal dringend hier grundsanieren, weil selbst diese Säule wird uns jetzt langsam, also die ist nicht weggebrochen oder sowas, die ist ja nicht so, als ob es ihnen da schlecht gehen würde. Aber die haben ja Microsoft ja ganz offene Spots. Leute, setzt keine Google Docs ein, weil Microsoft Office ist ja viel besser für dich.
Hast du diese Geschichte gelesen mit diesem Mittelmanagement bei Microsoft? Da sind Leute befragt worden, wie viele Leute zwischen ihnen und Steve Ballmer eine Position hatten in der Hierarchie, als sie angefangen haben und als sie zuletzt rausgeschmissen wurden. Es war so, dass sie irgendwie kamen und dann waren fünf Leute zwischen ihnen und Steve Ballmer und als sie gingen, waren 14 Hierarchie-Ebenen zwischen ihnen und Steve Ballmer. So, your mileage may vary. Es gab da verschiedene Leute, die befragt wurden und die Zahlen gingen von 11 bis 15 oder so was. Ach du Scheiße. Mit anderen Worten, da hat sich mittlerweile eine bürokratische Krake da irgendwie innerhalb dieses Unternehmens entwickelt. Ich glaube, die Wahrheit über Microsoft weiß man wahrscheinlich in dem Moment, wo man Dilbert liest. Dilbert war ja schon immer so diese Vision des nicht funktionierenden Wirtschaftsunternehmens. Und da finde ich passt das irgendwie wunderbar. Dilbert ist manchmal auch so ein bisschen schwer, ist nicht immer so lustig, aber in den letzten Tagen war es wieder mal extrem lustig, als irgendwie ankam, ja wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie unser Projekt und wir haben gemerkt, dass es irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Aber wir werden es nicht einstellen, weil das wäre ja irgendwie embarrassing, sondern wir werden stattdessen noch mehr Geld ausgeben, so viel Geld, wie irgendwie möglich ist und hoffen, dass das Upper-Management dann gekranzelt wird vor Budget-Riesens. Und das drückt irgendwie auch wunderbar aus, dass eigentlich so diese eigentliche Vision, worum es denn noch mal geht, nämlich wir wollen irgendwie hier Systeme machen, die konkurrenzfähig sind auf dem Markt, komplett irgendwie außen vor ist.
Ich glaube, dass das hölle kompliziert ist, ein Unternehmen ab einer bestimmten Größe tatsächlich auf dem Markt auszurichten. Und die Leute dazu zu bringen, dass sie nicht innerhalb ihrer eigenen Hierarchie denken, sondern nach außen hin zu denken. Das kann man, sondern sozusagen auf die Konkurrenz gucken. Ich glaube, das ist echt richtig Arbeit. Und dass Apple das schafft, ist...
Ja, das hat Apple geschafft. Auf der letzten, was, Sherwala-Meeting, wo Steve Jobs gesagt hat, oder wie war es, Tim Cook? Ich glaube, Tim Cook war es, wo sie meinten, es ist nicht unser Ziel, beliebig groß zu werden. Sondern wir sagen täglich nein zu guten Ideen. Und bei uns kommt es vor allem darauf an, dass wir eben diesen Fokus nicht verlieren. Und ich glaube, das ist ihnen einfach hervorragend gelungen. Sie haben derzeit einfach einen verdammt guten Fokus. Und es ist schon geradezu erschütternd zu sehen, wie viel Erfolg sie da erzeugen.
Was natürlich nach wie vor eine spannende Frage ist, zu wie groß ist der Anteil von Steve Jobs und zwar der persönliche, nicht ersetzbare Anteil von Steve Jobs an dieser Fokussierung? Ich glaube, der ist höher als uns recht ist.
Na, das ist sicherlich nicht unerheblich.
Wenn Steve mal weg ist, dann wird der Apple-Aktienkurs einen richtigen Satz nach unten machen.
Na gut, Steve war ja schon mal weg. Und der Aktienkurs hat es nicht gemacht.
Man hatte das Gefühl, dass es ihm irgendwie so...
Man kann sagen, man hatte die Hoffnung, dass er wiederkommt. Und der Aktienkurs hat auch einen schönen Satz gemacht. Dieser Vortrag, die Macworld fand ja statt.
Das war das, wo es früher immer Produkte gab.
Genau. Wo es jetzt auch noch Produkte gibt, aber eben nicht von Apple.
Die sind gar nicht mehr da. Nicht mal mehr mit einem Stand oder sowas.
Genau. Die sind einfach nicht da. Und ich glaube, das ist auch nicht so schlimm, weil letzten Endes mal ehrlich...
Ich glaube, es ist die Macworld, das ist furchtbar.
Keine Ahnung, wie die das jetzt konkret bewertet haben, aber ich denke, die verstehen sich halt einfach als das, was sie im Wesentlichen jetzt sind, nämlich irgendwie die Community, wo die ganzen Software-Hersteller hinkommen, die diese Plattform einfach beleben. Und ich glaube nicht, dass es Apple wirklich erfordert dort, weil man kennt eh schon alle die Produkte, die Apple Stores sind ein paar Meter weiter. Was willst du denn nochmal, das zehnte Mal das MacBook angucken und über den Mac Pro streicheln? Ich glaube nicht, dass das wichtig ist. Wie auch immer. Ich wollte auf was anderes hinaus. Es gab eine Keynote, zweierlei, also eine von John Grover, Daring Fireball, der über die zehn Sachen geredet hat, die er sozusagen bedenklich findet. Also wo Apple die irgendwie schwierig werden können.
Hast du die angehört?
Ja, sehr schöner Vortrag, interessante Sachen. Ich kann gerade die zehn Sachen nicht auswendig wiedergeben, aber einer war Steve Jobs, wo er sich genau über diesen Punkt unterhalten hat, welche Wirkung das Letztende hat. Ich stimme ihm insofern zu, als dass er meint, naja, das ist schon auch ein Problem, aber am Ende kann man sich auch andere Dinge anschauen, wo er auch nicht mehr ist und wo Firmen auch noch erfolgreich sind, wie zum Beispiel Pixar. Also Pixar ist nach wie vor absolut outstanding. Jedes einzelne ihrer Produkte, die sie rausbringen, ist ein mega Erfolg gewesen. Seit langer, langer Zeit, vor allem seit den letzten zehn Jahren, wo er eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur noch für Apple arbeitet. Auch da ist es ihm gelungen, eine Unternehmenskultur zu hinterlassen, die self-sustained ist. Man kann jetzt beliebig darüber orakelen, ob das nun sein wird. Das werden wir dann einfach sehen.
Bei Apple hat er das schon mal nicht geschafft.
Was hat er nicht geschafft?
Also als Steve Jobs das letzte Mal bei Apple war, da hat das nicht, als er das erste Mal weggegangen ist, hat es offensichtlich diese Kultur nicht übergeben.
Ich glaube, der ist seitdem auch mächtig gereift. Von daher sieht man auch, es hängt dann doch nicht immer alles nur an einer Person. Tatsache ist natürlich, er hat jetzt schon eine ganze Menge vorangebracht. Und ich glaube aber, dass das schon auch nachhaltig sein kann. Dass das nicht in alle Ewigkeit so weitergeht. Gut, aber interessiert uns das. Ich will nicht über Apple nachdenken in 20 Jahren, sondern über Apple nachdenken in den nächsten 20 Monaten.
Ja klar.
Das ist spannend. So, haben wir jetzt eigentlich diese ganze Patentgeschichte irgendwie hinter uns gebracht?
Ja, lass mal.
Wir sind sehr weit geschweift, oder? Sehr, sehr, sehr. Wir entschuldigen uns. Das ist schon mal. Nächstes Thema, haben wir überhaupt eins?
Flash auf den Palm!
Hab ich gemacht. Also, was steckt dahinter? Palm OS, was ist das? Version 1.4? Also WebOS 1.4?
Ich kann es ja leider nicht ausprobieren, weil...
Hat jetzt auch eine Flash später. Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon mal jemand gesehen hat. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber es ist halt jetzt im Prinzip die Fortsetzung der Diskussion, die wir letztes Mal schon hatten. Vielleicht halten wir sie auch mal kurz. Was ist eigentlich seitdem passiert? Also, wir haben uns darüber unterhalten und ein Aspekt, den wir so überhaupt nicht besprochen haben, war, ob denn das überhaupt sinnvoll ist mit dem Flash auf den mobilen Devices in der Form, wie Flash heute ist.
Ich glaube, ich habe es vorsichtig angesprochen, ja.
Aber gab ja auch diesen schönen Artikel bei Roughly Drafted, wo dann jemand irgendwie mal zusammengefasst hat, was er eigentlich so als Probleme sieht. Nämlich, dass erstmal viele Event-Modelle, von denen man so annimmt, dass sie da sind und die bei der Installed Base von Flash-Content einfach vorausgesetzt wird, sich auf ein Touch-Gerät sowieso nicht so machen. Das hat was mit der Größe von Control zu tun, das hat was mit so spezifischen Sachen wie Hover zu tun. Du hast halt einfach keine Maus, die du irgendwo drauf zeigen lassen kannst, sondern du hast einfach nur den Touch als solchen und der ist relativ diffus. Größe von User-Interface-Elementen, viele Spiele da draußen, wo ja heute immer gesagt wird, naja, wenn das iPad keinen Flash hat, dann kann man ja diese Spiele nicht spielen. Selbst wenn es Flash hätte, könnte man diese Spiele wahrscheinlich nicht spielen, weil man eben keine Maus hat.
Genau, diese Argumentation von Adobe, alle Spiele im Netz könnte man sofort spielen, die ist einfach erfunden, die ist nicht wahr. Das ist, wenn ein Spiel Tastatur benötigt, schon allein geht es ja nicht. Man müsste also all diese Programme total anpassen.
Das wird nicht stattfinden.
Das würde bei einigen Programmen wahrscheinlich sogar stattfinden, bei anderen aber nicht.
Genau, bei denen, bei denen es stattfindet, kann man genauso die Energie auch in eine webbasierte Anwendung stellen.
Das ist natürlich immer so eine Frage. Ich hänge davon ab, wie komplex die Software ist, wenn man jetzt ein ausgebildeter Flash-Entwickler ist und du sagst, alles klar, hier muss ich mal ein bisschen Hover wegnehmen. So wichtig ist das. Das hängt sicherlich immer vom konkreten Projekt ab, wie viel Aufwand das wäre. Aber die Aussage bringt das iPad installierter Flash drauf. Wenn Apple da Flash drauf installieren würde, könnte man all diese Inhalte sofort, ohne Änderung, ohne Einschränkungen nutzen. Das ist einfach falsch, stimmt nicht. Kann man nicht, geht halt nicht. Die können kein Hover, geht halt nicht. Die Controls sind zu klein. Man müsste sehr viel anpassen, damit es funktioniert. Muss man auch bei einigen Webseiten? Ist ja auch gar keine Frage. Apple hat sich da sehr viel Mühe gegeben, aber alles funktioniert eben auch an Webseiten, nicht auf dem iPhone. Das wäre bei Flash nochmal einen ganzen Zacken schlimmer. Schon allein beim Videoplayer. Dass er anfängt, die Kontrollelemente auszublenden, sobald du die Maus nicht mehr bewegst. Das ist ein Hover-Effekt.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was ich palm und so weiter davon verspreche, Flash auszuliefern.
Ich meine, den geht es halt auch nicht gut.
Ja, aber jetzt geht es ihnen besser oder was? Jetzt haben sie ein Verkaufsargument.
Jetzt können sie sich einen Laden hinstellen und können sagen, wenn du dabei...
Ja, aber was bitte funktioniert denn jetzt wohl auf dem WebOS, was vorher nicht ging? Flash! Du kannst es doch nicht bedienen.
Jetzt musst du auch nicht dazu sagen. Guck mal, wenn da jetzt jemand bei Verizon im Laden steht und der hat zwei Geräte zur Auswahl. Auf der einen Seite ist Motorola Droid und auf der anderen Seite hat er den Palm Pre.
Du meinst, er hat doch Flash, ach, dann nehme ich doch den.
Das ist ein Argument.
Ich glaube, die Leute, die sich für so ein Gerät entscheiden, die wissen gar nicht, welcher Teil einer Webseite, die sie vielleicht interessant finden könnten, jetzt Flash ist und was nicht.
Dann erklärt ihnen das, Herr freundlicher Verkäufer, gerne.
YouTube ist Flash!
Na gut, das mag dann von dem Verkäufer abhängen. Das stimmt schon.
Das ist, guck mal, das ist ein Bundel, den kannst du auf die Liste setzen und das wird sie auch.
Wir werden das einfach beobachten, das ist jetzt irgendwie verfügbar. Ich glaube nicht, dass da sehr viel bei rauskommen wird. Ich denke, dass der Kick jetzt in Richtung mit Web-Standards denselben Scheiß machen. Der ist jetzt einfach gegeben und wir werden da binnen eines Jahres mehr Ergebnisse sehen, als wir uns derzeit wahrscheinlich realistisch vorstellen können. So, was wissen wir denn noch? Wir wissen, dass das iPad kommt und wir wissen auch in etwa wann.
Ende April, ne?
In Deutschland? Ende April. Also Welt, also wie war das? WLAN-Version, 3. April.
In Amerika?
In Amerika und alles andere, also alle Geräte einschließlich UMTS-Varianten des iPads in allen, nee nicht in allen Ländern, in einigen Ländern. Eine Liste, da ist Deutschland dabei.
Das sind in Europa nur vier Länder oder sowas, ne? Das sind gar nicht so wahnsinnig viele. Deutschland, Frankreich.
Ich muss noch mal gucken.
Aber auf jeden Fall bin ich so froh, ich bin so froh, dass die UMTS-Version und die WLAN-Version gleichzeitig kommt. Ich hatte mir schon echt so, wie kriege ich das jetzt hin? Kaufe ich mir jetzt für die zwei Wochen das WLAN-Gerät und tausche es dann wieder um und hole dann die UMTS-Version? Das ist echt gut, dass das alles gleichzeitig kommt. Jetzt muss ich bloß noch irgendwie rauskriegen, wie ich bis dahin so eine Mikrosim auftreibe.
Du kannst dir aber noch überlegen, vorher noch in die USA zu fahren. Ich guck grad mal, welche Länder das waren, weil das ist ja auch sehr interessant, dass sie jetzt das so auf wenige Länder beschränken. Ich frage mich, warum?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich, vielleicht können sie nicht, Kapazitätsprobleme vielleicht?
Du meinst, dass sie nicht genug Geräte liefern können?
Dass sie nicht genügend Geräte herstellen können. Weil es gab ja so Gerüchte, dass es in der Fabrik in der das hergestellt wird, dass du irgendwie streichst und weißt ja toll, was kommt.
Es gab auch Gerüchte, dass diese Gerüchte alle nicht stimmen.
Gab's auch?
Ja, gab's auch.
Dann bringe ich jetzt das Gerücht in die Welt, dass die Gerüchte die Gerüchte nicht stimmen. Übergerüchtet.
Turning Point. Ab jetzt alles anders. Ich versuche gerade diese Informationen zu kriegen, aber...
Ja, wir werden uns alle iPads kaufen und Mikrosims probieren, dafür aufzutreiben. Weißt du was zum Thema Mikrosim? Gibt es da schon Kündig? Kann das irgendwer schon? Gibt es da irgendwie bei O2 oder bei der Telekom oder sowas schon?
Ich weiß, dass alles, was du brauchst, um aus einer Sim eine Mikrosim zu machen, eine Haushaltsschere ist. Und von daher mache ich mir nicht sehr viel Gedanken darüber.
Ja, ich will aber trotzdem...
Also ich habe noch nichts davon gehört, dass ein Provider diese Sims rausbringen will, allerdings werden sie es alle tun.
Sie werden es alle haben, klar.
Hauptsache, sie bauen das in ihre Scheiß-Mac-Box ein. Also, Schweiz, Frankreich, Italien, Spanien, Großbritannien, Australien und Japan. Weitere Länder folgen später im laufenden Jahr. Das ist aber echt eine interessante Auswahl.
Schweiz ja, Österreich nicht.
Stimmt, Österreich ist nicht dabei. Das habt ihr jetzt von euren guten 3G-Tarifen und den ganzen unkomplizierten Bim-Bim. Das ist die gerechte Strafe.
Ihr müsst über die Grenze nach Deutschland fahren, um euch ein iPad zu kaufen.
Zoll, sag ich nur, Zoll.
Gibt's doch gar keinen Zoll.
Der wird einfach draufgeschlagen. Wiener Akzent, 50 Euro mehr. Wie sagt ihr, Hochdeutschkurse sind dann wieder groß im Modus.
Ich hoffe, falls wir jemals Höhere in Österreich hatten, das können wir jetzt an den Klagen kriegen.
Schweiz, Frankreich, Italien, Spanien, Großbritannien. Ausgerechnet Australien und Japan. Was ist denn da nicht dabei? Österreich hatten wir schon. Das sind schon ein bisschen die wirtschaftlichen Schwergewichte. Naja, müssen wir mal schauen. Tatsache ist, ich werde mir eins kaufen. Das steht total außer Frage. Bestellen kann man leider noch keins.
Ich finde aber lustig, dass so eine übliche Schlagzeile war, iPad-Auslieferung verspätet sich. Da verspätet sich gar nichts. Sie halten sich an den Termin, den sie für Amerika angekündigt haben.
Naja, ist alles im Plan.
Und für Deutschland und für den Rest der Welt hatten sie nie einen Termin angekündigt und haben es jetzt gemacht.
Sie haben auch für dieses UMTS-Gerät nichts angekündigt. Sie haben nur gesagt, das WLAN-Teil ist dann und dann da und das andere kommt später.
Nein, 60 Tage und 90 Tage haben sie gesagt.
Ja, das haut ja auch hin.
Ja, Amerika haut das alles hin.
Das ist gut.
Wahrscheinlich werden sie auch sagen, dein iPad teurer als gedacht.
Auf jeden Fall ist festzustellen, dass der Hype um das iPad nicht abappt. Das ist ein bisschen ähnlich wie beim iPhone. Das ist zumindest meine Wahrnehmung.
Lass mich gerade sagen, dass auf jeden Fall von T-Mobile wird eine Micro-SIM kommen und von den anderen auch. Die gesamte Branche wird diese Micro-SIMs dann pünktlich haben.
Ja, da werden sie auch schön angeschissen, wenn sie das irgendwie nicht machen würden.
Wahrscheinlich haben die dann im Laden so kleine Stanzen stehen, wo sie reinpappen können, die SIM-Karten, und dann hast du so eine Micro-SIM.
Und du kaufst aber UMTS?
Ja, klar.
Ich auch.
Vor allem jetzt, wo ich gesehen habe, dass es offensichtlich so ist, dass das WLAN-Teil nicht als Bluetooth-Client an ein iPhone sich Internet holen kann.
Ach, damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt keine Sekunde gerechnet, aber okay.
Warum? Ja, aber warum?
Weil sie die Geräte standalone haben wollen. Weil es eigentlich auch albern ist. Leute machen Verträge mit Firmen, die euch beliebig viele SIM-Karten hinterher schmeißen. Und dann packt ihr in jedes dieser Geräte halt eine SIM-Karte rein. Aus die Maus.
Ja, aber das ist doch eine ganz andere Entscheidung, ob du 3G in deinem Gerät haben willst oder ob es vielleicht nur ab und zu mal vielleicht auch mal brauchst und dann nimmst du halt irgendwie dein iPhone.
Ich fänd's auch toll, wenn es ginge, aber ich hab bei Apple keine Sekunde damit gerechnet.
Ich find's doof. Also ich find das wirklich blöd. Weil das schränkt dieses WLAN-Teil unnötig ein.
Grund für den Witten Jailbreak.
Ja, aber sowas finde ich wirklich Quatsch, insbesondere im Hinblick darauf, dass das Teil ja auch irgendwie autark sein soll. Na ja, gut. Aber ich kann ihre Argumentation immer wieder nachvollziehen. Nachvollziehen heißt immer nur, ich weiß wie sie denken. Das heißt nicht, dass ich der gleichen Meinung bin. Aber na ja, ich weiß nicht, ich finde das blöd. Wir sollten vielleicht noch kurz über den Upstore reden. Da ist ja einiges passiert.
Ach stimmt, ja.
Und wie sich das da überhaupt an dieser Front mit den Entwicklern verhält. Also ich habe...
Böse, böse Hackertools sind jetzt rausgeflogen.
Ja, es sind viele Hackertools rausgeflogen. Auf der einen Seite wird natürlich gleich wieder Jehova geschrien. Ja, was ist rausgeflogen? Sind diese WLAN-Scanner rausgeflogen? Ich frage mich, warum die eigentlich jetzt erst rausgeflogen sind. Ich habe mich immer gefragt, warum die überhaupt da waren, weil die ja Private Apis...
Ach, das sind Private Apis?
So, habe ich das verstanden?
Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Also ich habe WLAN-Scanner gerne und viel eingesetzt im Urlaub, wo ich kein Roaming nutzen wollte. Also so im europäischen Ausland.
Welche Funktionalität hast du von diesen Tools bekommen, die du nicht auch mit deiner normalen WLAN-Handzeige... Da gibt es geile Sachen.
Du nimmst einfach... Du startest das App, steckst es in die Tasche und das kostet natürlich ohne Ende Akku, aber es guckt die ganze Zeit über, so alle 10 Sekunden oder sowas, habe ich WLANs in der Nähe, welche davon sind offen, probiert sich dann mit denen zu verbinden, probiert deine Webseite aufzurufen und wenn das klappt, sagt er dir Bescheid.
Ok, also das Ganze ausprobieren wird gleich mitautomatisiert. Es ist nicht nur eine Liste anzeigen, sondern die wählen sich halt auch an. Ein Freund von mir hat mal so ein Device gebaut, so aus so einem kleinen Netgear-Router, irgendwie mit PHP zusammengekloppt, ganz einfach. So ein Tool, was einfach so autark sich Internet verschafft. Das heißt, der guckt halt einfach rum, wo sind irgendwelche WLANs und geht dann irgendwie los und probiert irgendwie alle Standard-Passwörter aus, schnitt sich irgendwo ein oder versucht irgendwie, die WEP-Verschlüsselung zu knacken und so weiter. Und agiert einfach so lange, bis er ein Netz hat. Und stellt das dann zur Verfügung. Piffiges Gerät. Nein, keine Ahnung, wo man das runterladen kann, bevor ihr fragt. Ich glaube, das ist eine private Entwicklung.
Schade.
Ja gut, und der Porno fliegt raus.
Das muss Amerikaner für Porno halten.
Ja, das ist halt schwierig. Was wirklich schwierig daran ist, dass amerikanische Maßstäbe da jetzt angesetzt werden. Stell mir mal vor, was es bedeuten würde, wenn Apple seinen Sitz in Teheran hätte. Du durftest wahrscheinlich noch nicht mein Gesicht einer Frau zeigen.
Irgendjemand hat doch wohl, ein Entwickler hat einen Apple Namen, ich weiß jetzt nicht, in welchem Zusammenhang. Irgendwann hab ich es schon mal erzählt, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es hier erzählt habe, gefragt, wie sieht denn das eigentlich aus? Was ist denn jetzt, also ist denn, was ist denn da erlaubt? Dann war wohl die Antwort, keine Haut.
Das fand er dann nicht so lustig.
Das fand er dann nicht so lustig. Also insofern, so weit von Teheran ist das gar nicht. Teheran ist doch relativ offen.
Iran ist doch gar nicht so, siehst du? Es ist schon wirklich eine merkwürdige Entscheidung, weil auf der anderen Seite ist Playboy dabei und so weiter. Es ist nicht so, dass du das nicht hast. Ich fand es dann cool, dass da ausgerechnet Springer sich dann in dem Moment das erste Mal über Pressefreiheit Gedanken macht, wo irgendwie die Titten untersagt werden. Das lässt dir echt tief blicken. Also diese Reaktionen aus der deutschen Verlagswelt sind schon wirklich absurd.
Aber ist das nicht lustig? Das ist doch genau das, was wir hier vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit prophezeit haben. Und jetzt, dass es absolut absehbar ist, dass das passieren wird. Und jetzt passiert es einfach. Das ist genau die Reaktion, mit der alle gerechnet haben. Das ist echt spannend. Das muss man nach wie vor konstatieren. Apple ist die falsche App-Store, um damit zu versuchen, Content anzubieten. Weil dann fängt man sich tatsächlich auf einen potenziellen Punkt ein, an den man sich abhängig macht. Tja, also wenn man so ein umfassendes Nachrichtenangebot liefern will, dann brot man bei Apple, glaube ich, schon in die Falle zu treten. Sodass da irgendwann mal wieder jemand vom Review reinguckt und sagt, hä? Eine Brustwarze? Schmeiß mal raus.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, ob das stattfinden wird und wenn ja wann, dass eben Anwendungen sich auch wirklich als Web-Applikationen mal präsentieren. Weil es ist ja auch möglich, über das Web eine Anwendung zu installieren.
Google ist ja da ja ganz groß drinnen.
Sind sie?
Jaja, klar. Jede zweite Google-Anwendung gibt es als... Also in Amerika haben sie ja Google Voice.
Als installierbar oder als Bookmark.
Was meinst du mit als installierbar?
Also ich hab hier neulich diesen ebook-Reader installiert. Wie heißt der noch gleich?
Was würde mich jetzt mal interessieren?
eBiz-Reader, wie der Vogel eBiz. B-I-S, so. Und da hast du dann irgendwie so einen netten Button und dann installiert sich das Teil schon so mit dem Hinweis, ich brauche so und so viel Megabyte auf deinem Computer. Und erscheint dann irgendwie so als Icon und dann startest du das Teil und dann hast du halt da wirklich ein Programm. Ja, was JavaScript ist und was natürlich auch mit dem Internet kommuniziert, aber wo schon so der Code auf deinem Computer liegt, auf deinem Iphone liegt. Und natürlich auch eine lokale Datenbank. Also was wirklich das Application-Modell von HTML5 benutzt, um eben... Ich strahle hier glaube ich gerade ein.
Warte mal, das muss ich mal...
Oder ja mal alle mal installieren. Ebisreader war auch so ein Tipp bei John Grober. Und da dachte ich mir dann halt auch so... Weil das kann dann so vom User-Interface her nicht so vollständig mithalten mit einer nativen Anwendung. Aber es ist eben auch nicht so, dass es vollständig unmöglich wäre, eine Anwendung auszuliefern, die sich eben vollständig diesen Upstore-Bedingungen entzieht.
Naja, also das ist... Was die jetzt machen mit der Installation, das ist...
Da geht's nur um die lokale Datenbank, oder?
Naja, du kannst ja... Ich hab das ja mit... Ich hab ja diesen Edwin-Client irgendwann mal entwickelt und ich hab das da ziemlich weit getrieben. Weil... Also es gibt... Aber nicht so weit, wie es technisch möglich wäre. Was ich gemacht habe, ist... Ich hab... Also du kannst ja eigentlich alles in der Datenbank speichern. Es gibt eine lokale SQL-Datenbank und du hast dieses Local Storage-Objekt. Das ist eigentlich noch besser geeignet dafür. Das gab es damals aber noch nicht. Und da kannst du beliebige Daten reinschmeißen. Da kannst du natürlich auch HTML-Code reinschmeißen. Da kannst du CSS-Code reinschmeißen. Wenn du CSS-Code reinschmeißen kannst, kannst du auch Bilder reinschmeißen, weil du per DataURL die in deinem CSS-Code embedden kannst. Und JavaScript-Code sowieso. Das heißt, du kannst eigentlich alle wesentlichen Elemente da reinpappen. Was du jetzt noch brauchst, und das ist dieser lokale Speicherplatz, den sie anfragen, da kannst du vorher sagen, wie viel Speicherplatz deine Applikation braucht, wie viel willst du denn haben. Und wenn das mehr ist als ein bestimmter Bereich, ich glaube ein Megabyte oder so was, dann kommt da so eine Anfrage des Betriebssystems. Das Einzige, wofür du jetzt noch eine Internetanbindung brauchst, ist quasi das Bootstrappen. Die eigentliche Funktionalität, die du sagst, alles klar, ich greife jetzt mal auf die Datenbank zu und lese den ersten JavaScript-Code aus. Und das kannst du über die Manifest-Datei auf jeden Fall hinbiegen. Du kannst definieren, dass du sagst, bestimmte Teile der Webseite werden einfach lokal gespeichert und die speichert dann das iPhone für dich ab. Was daran der Nachteile ist, ich hab nie so 100% die Kontrolle darüber gekriegt, die war glaube ich auch buggy schlicht und ergreifend, wann er sich Änderungen doch nachlädt. Da werden Events abgeschickt, aber so richtig 100% ich hab das nicht hingekriegt. Die werden sich jetzt einfach damit beschäftigt haben und schon hast du so eine Applikation offline. Klar, das funktioniert einwandfrei. Und ich glaube, das wird von Google teilweise genutzt.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht den Anschein erreden, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass das gleichwertig wäre. Ist es nicht, weil man hat eben auf viele APIs so in dem Maße keinen Zugriff. Nicht wahr, wenn du da mit den Acceleratoren und Sensoren und so weiter arbeiten willst, dann willst du halt einfach mal mit nativen Code wirklich in der offiziellen API arbeiten. It's not the same thing. Auf der anderen Seite ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass es das nicht gibt. Und bei der Bewertung des iPhone als Plattform und dass die Plattform ja nicht so offen wäre, muss man glaube ich schon zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Nämlich das Einfallstor Web, was weder irgendwie zensiert noch reglementiert noch reduziert ist, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, wo sich derzeit eigentlich so das modernste Web-Environment eigentlich überhaupt findet auf irgendeinem Computer. Und dann eben noch zu dieser Apple-gefeaturete ihr dürft Teil unseres Produktes sein App Store Umgebung. Die Diskussion hatten wir auch schon mehrfach. Ich weiß auch noch ganz am Anfang war ja auch sehr umstritten, aber ich hab das schon auch immer so gesehen, dass es eben schon einen Unterschied gibt zwischen die Plattform, die allen offen steht und die Plattform, die vielen offen steht, aber die nicht im eigentlichen Sinne offen ist, sondern die eben von Apple geöffnet worden ist, aber zu ihren Bedingungen und das hat eben auch Grenzen. So, was haben wir denn noch auf der Uhr?
Also Google Apps unterstützen.
Wir wollten ja eine Kurzdurchsendung machen, oder? So richtig gelingt uns das, glaube ich, auch nicht so richtig. Ah ja, genau. Eine Sache, die noch aufkam, und zwar ging das, glaube ich, über diese, war das wieder so eine Suchanzeige für Leute, die mitarbeiten sollen bei Apple, dass sie Werbung in das SDK integrieren wollen. Das war, glaube ich, der Satz, den man da rauslesen konnte. Hast du nicht gesehen?
Doch, doch, natürlich habe ich das gesehen.
Was ich da jetzt mal so mit zusammenbaue, ist, dass sie quasi das Einblenden von Werbung in Applikationen als Bestandteil des Software Development Kids machen.
Sie werden sich nicht umsonst eine Werbebude gekauft haben.
Naja, das ist offensichtlich die Strategie, die sie da fahren. Ich frage jetzt, was bedeutet das? Das bedeutet, dass wenn ich jetzt eine Anwendung schreibe, dass so wie ich mir Google Maps einblenden kann, kann ich mir dann auch irgendwie Werbung machen. Und ich vermute mal, das wird dann auf so ein ähnliches Revenue-Modell rauslaufen wie mit dem gesamten App Store. Du kriegst irgendwie 70% der Einnahmen und Apple kriegt irgendwie 30%. Wahrscheinlich werden sie das machen, einfach weil das dann jeder sofort im Kopf hat.
Und die Werbung wird offensichtlich in HTML5 gemacht. Weil ich glaube, ein Teil der Anzeige war, ich suche jetzt noch mal raus gleich, aber ein Teil der Anzeige war, sie suchen HTML5, JavaScript, bla bla bla, Experten, to bring advertisement to the next level.
Also es war schon relativ naheliegend. Was sonst? Über GIFs sind wir schon hinaus. Und Webviews können sie überall anzeigen. So geht es dann halt auch in Webseiten.
Genau. Wollen sie es vielleicht auch in Webseiten direkt integrieren?
Vorstellbar. Ich meine, wenn es Teil des SDK ist, weiß ich nicht.
Also du kannst dir auf der einen Seite eine SDK-RP anbieten, die das in dein Coco-Touch-Up einbaut. Und dann eben da ein Webview aufmacht mit ein bisschen HTML5 drin. Und parallel dazu kannst du... Also HTML5 bietet sich natürlich auch noch aus anderen Gründen an. Nämlich, dass die entsprechenden Anbieter, die da Werbung reinpacken wollen, dass die ein Tool haben, mit dem sie schnell arbeiten können und nicht irgendwie Coco lernen müssen oder eine eigene Sprache oder was das heißt. Aber auf der anderen Seite könnte man diese Werbung dann auch schön in so eine Web-App wie diesen Iris-Rider einbauen oder Spiegel Online, die mobile Version hier. Werbung kannst du übrigens auch anzeigen. Also wahrscheinlich dann auch auf einer anderen Plattform, auch auf Android. Warum denn das nur für die eigene Plattform machen eigentlich?
Aber wem hauen sie denn jetzt mit dieser Nummer gegen Schienenbein? Die Developer werden wieder froh locken oder auch nicht? Also nach dem Motto, oh jetzt ist es aber einfach, ich drag mir dann irgendwie einfach mein Ad-View irgendwie in meinem Interface-Bilder, aber schreibe ich in meinem Programm rein, dann habe ich da irgendwie auch Werbung und damit ist irgendwie der ganze Finanzflow und Vertragskram ist drin. Und dann habe ich über so einen API, kann ich irgendwie aufrufen, was ich alles nicht haben will.
Naja, aber das ist doch jetzt eher eine rhetorische Frage, wenn sie damit ans Schienenbein treten, oder? Welches Unternehmen, das nebenbei noch eine Suchmaschine betreibt, verdient viel Geld mit Beherrung im Internet? Da fällt keiner ein.
Aber es sind ja auch nicht die einzigen, die da jetzt unterwegs sind. Also gerade, dass sie jetzt sich diese ganzen mobilen Companies gekauft haben, zeigt ja, dass da noch mal so eine...
Na gut, hat sich seine mobile Company gekauft und Apple hat sich seine.
Genau. Was ich schon überhaupt sehr interessant fand, dass sie nicht selber schon sowieso schon diese Company waren. Dass da in dem mobilen Bereich sich hat noch was eigenes entwickeln können, was schon nicht aus Google herauskam.
Ich weiß nicht, meinst du nicht, die haben das einfach... Also, Google mobile Anzeigen gab's schon?
Na gut, aber es gab AdMob und AdMob waren irgendwie die größten. Und wie ist nochmal gleich diese Bude, die sich Apple einfach hat? Quattro, irgendwas, kannte ich gar nicht.
Ja, kann ich auch nicht. AdMob, die haben sich von vornherein relativ stark darauf konzentriert, bild ich mir ein, entsprechend die APs für eben diese Coco Touch-AP zur Verfügung zu stellen und so was. Dieses Element, was dir nur reinpappen brauchst und schon hast du Werbung in deinem Link.
In Programme.
Als Frameworks bereitzustellen.
Genau. Und das haben sie garantiert auch für Android gemacht. Und haben dann eben Werbung auch in diesem üblichen Format angeboten und so was. Und da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass Google da einfach ein bisschen Lama war.
Okay, verstehe, diese Spezialisierung ist wirklich in Ups reinzubringen und nicht nur auf mobile Geräte. Nachvollziehbar. Ja, also das steht uns bestimmt bevor, wenn auch nicht unbedingt mit der nächsten 4.0-Version.
Das werden wir so peu à peu sehen. Ich glaube, das wird relativ plötzlich einfach passieren. Das wird einfach da sein.
Auf einmal überall Werbung. Na ja gut, ich meine, das ändert ja nichts. Also eigentlich ist es für uns egal, weil es gibt auch jetzt schon Programme, die das tun. Und ob sie Akzeptanz finden oder nicht, das hängt dann eben sehr davon ab, was sie einem so präsentieren und wie sie sich einem präsentieren. Und ob man das machen möchte und ob man bereit ist, für bezahlte Software auch noch Werbung zu ertragen.
Ja, aber vielleicht geht das ja dann wirklich in diesen Zeitungsmarkt rein. Vielleicht ist das ja dann, dass die Entwicklungen, auf die sie jetzt die ganze Zeit über warten, dass Apple sagt, ach, für Zeitungen bezahlen, bloß weil es auf dem iPad ist, wird auch niemand. Warum sollten die Leute das tun, wenn sie das in Webseiten machen können? Macht es doch so, wie ihr es schon immer gemacht habt. Macht es über Werbung.
Ja, das heißt, jetzt nehmen sie den Zeitungen auch noch ihre Werbekontakte weg. Zuerst mussten die ganzen Software-Entwickler auf ihre Kundenkontakte verzichten, sonst die Zeitungsanbieter dürfen jetzt auch nicht mit ihren Werbekunden zusammenarbeiten. Schwierig, weil davon hängt glaube ich auch eine Menge ab. Also das ist schon auch wichtig, dass wenn man Werbung macht, dass man im Rahmen eines Produktes wie einer Zeitung, dass man eben den Werbekunden auch sehr genau bieten kann, wer angesprochen wird. Das ist für die schon so wichtig. Das breite Streuen von Werbung funktioniert eh nicht.
Na ja, ich glaube, dass im Netz langsam das Umfeld wichtig wird. Es ist genauso wie man seine Werbung, egal wer zuguckt, man möchte seinen teuren Mercedes nicht nachts um 3 zwischen irgendwelchen Pornoclips sehen. Das wird im Webseek wahrscheinlich über Gott sei Dank auch durchsetzen.
So, und nachdem wir unser iPad gekauft haben, kommen wir uns noch ein neues iPhone. Denn es wird ein neues iPhone kommen dieses Jahr.
Jede Wette.
Da gibt es noch gar keine Gerüchte. Wie komisch. Oder gab es schon welche? Gab es bestimmt welche. Ja, gar keine. Irgendeinen hat... Somebody was dating the obvious again. Ich geh schwer davon aus, dass irgendwie iPhone OS 4.0 und irgendwie ein neues iPhone, und ich hoffe, sie hängen nicht noch einen Buchstaben hinten dran.
Der Friseur meiner Freundin war... Es ist kein Witz, war in Polen auf irgendeiner Apple-Veranstaltung. Also natürlich nicht offiziell in einer Apple-Veranstaltung. Und schwört Stein und Bein, dass er da ein iPhone 4G gesehen hätte.
Das ist bestimmt wahr.
Das ist kein Witz, das ist wirklich...
Gut, dass wir das nicht ins Internet reingetragen haben, diese Information. Ich frag mich halt nur, wann mit diesem Exklusivvertrag Schluss ist, weil das ist irgendwie echt mega nervig.
Also die Welt hat doch da jetzt irgendwas... oder wer war es?
Es wurde gerüchtet... Irgendwas Printiges hat was rausgelassen. Ich weiß nicht, wer es war, aber es ging so in diese Richtung, dass das schon dann noch bis Ende des Jahres... Also im Prinzip, wie viele Jahre?
Es war bis Ende 2012. Nee, warte mal, es war bis Ende 2012.
Mit einer Kündigungsoption.
Mit einer Kündigungsoption Ende diesen Jahres.
Genau, das war drei Jahre nach Einführung des ersten iPhones in Deutschland gewesen.
Was so weit halbwegs plausibel klingt.
Na so war das doch. Irgendwie Juni kam das iPhone.
Nee, es kam ein bisschen später.
Und in Deutschland kam es dann später.
Genau, September kam es.
September in Deutschland schon.
Ich glaube, September 2007.
Ich glaube, es war erst im November.
Mann, ich war auf der Pressekonferenz. Kann auch November gewesen sein. Ja, das wär dann drei Jahre nach dem. Mal gucken, wie die Option ist.
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass ich so lange warte.
Muss es wieder italienisch sein?
Naja, muss nicht unbedingt italienisch sein.
In Belgien sind die günstigsten, oder? Ich hab einen guten Kontakt nach Belgien. Das nächste hol ich mir aus Belgien.
Also es nervt so ein bisschen mit dieser Warranty und so, aber es gibt ja auch so Reseller in Deutschland, aber die sind natürlich dann auch deutlich teuer.
Absolut teuer.
Aber dafür hast du halt auch irgendwie jemanden, wo du dein Telefon hinschicken kannst.
Ich hab gehört, dass wenn man lang genug, also wenn man deutlich genug jammert bei der Kündigung seines Mobilfunk-Vertrags, bei Vodafone oder O2 oder wie auch immer, dass sie einem dann irgendwie eins auch zukommen lassen. Dass sie einem dann auch irgendwie eins zu einem zukommen lassen.
Ja, ja, ich kenn auch mehrere Leute, denen das gelungen ist. Das waren aber alles Leute, die auch schon, sagen wir mal, Mobilfunk-Verträge haben, wo sie größere Beträge übertiefert haben. Das kann natürlich durchaus sein, ja. Also wenn man da, wie es seit zwei Monaten irgendwie ist.
Klar, als kleiner Prepaid-Kunde, werden die wahrscheinlich nicht sagen.
Ich bin auch schon ein totaler Dauerkunde, aber naja, mal gucken. Ich werde schon irgendwie Mittel und Wege finden. Auf irgendwas wollte ich hinaus. Wieso habe ich das eigentlich erwähnt? Mit dem Telefon? Ach ja, dass das jetzt ein Ende finden muss. Also ich denke nicht, dass ich so lange warten werde, bis es irgendwie ausläuft. Aber wenn es dann ausgelaufen ist, dann wird es natürlich richtig spannend. Dann wird es wirklich richtig spannend, was in Deutschland passiert. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die anderen dann auch entsprechend nachrüsten und das iPhone mit so etwas wie Visual-Voice-Mail auch über ihre Netze ausstatten. Was ja bisher noch nicht so passiert ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es nicht können oder ob sie es nicht wollen.
Ich glaube, sie würden es machen, wenn sie es könnten, oder? Also bei O2 hatte ich jetzt ja wirklich, die haben mir damals bei dem, als ich gesagt habe, mein Tethering geht nicht mehr, macht mir mal wieder Tethering. Also sie haben es nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt, aber mit dem 3.1.Update.
Aber mein Tethering geht ruhig nicht mehr.
Dein Tethering geht nicht mehr?
Naja, das können wir uns gleich nochmal anschauen. Ich habe es irgendwie verkackt.
Auf jeden Fall, da haben die sich aktiv bemüht. Ich glaube, sie probieren schon, da den besten Support für anzubieten, für die eingeholten iPhones.
Naja, es bleibt spannend. Wir wissen es wieder nicht. Ich habe wieder einen Punkt aufgeschrieben, wo wir eigentlich nichts wissen. Sind wir durch? Oder wolltest du jetzt noch wirklich hier über Start-up-Sounds reden?
Ja, da können wir mal darauf hinweisen. Das können wir einfach verlinken und brauchen wir nicht weiter zu machen. Ich finde das ja... Hast du mal diese Doku gesehen? Welcome to Macintosh? Die habe ich mir neulich mal wieder angeguckt. Die ist echt ganz süß, die kann man sich mal geben. Das ist, das erzählt so...
Ich habe das schon mal gehört, aber das ist noch nie auf meinem...
Das ist......
noch nie auf meinem Dings gelandet.
Gibt es das im Internet? Es gibt es im Internet. Ich weiß nicht, ob die offizielle Version im Internet ist. Ich glaube eher nicht, aber ansonsten kann man sich das bestimmen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da mal ein iTunes-Store gibt. Und das ist so eine ganz nette... Ja, das ist halt so, da erzählen hier, wie heißen sie gleich? Kawasaki? Der erzählt so ein bisschen. Andy Hertzfeld erzählt relativ viel, der nun einer der Väter der Max ist. Und es ist unter anderem auch ein sehr sympathisches Interview mit, und jetzt probiere ich gerade nebenbei den Namen herauszufinden, Jim Reeks. Unter anderem der, der den Soundmanager geschrieben hat, und so der Musiker bei Apple war. Und mit dem ist jetzt ein Interview mit irgendeinem holländischen OneMoreSing.nl Podcast, Web Video Podcast Dienst aufgetaucht. Und die haben das Schöne gemacht, sie haben das nicht synchronisiert, sondern schreien das Interview einfach so aus, das heißt, dass vorne am Anfang sind so 20 Sekunden holländisches Blaber, was ich nicht verstehe. Und danach ist einfach ein Interview mit diesem Typen. Und der ist irgendwie eine ziemlich coole Sau, wie ich finde. Und er erzählt da halt, wie er den McIntosh-Startup-Sound erfunden hat. Und der bis heute, also der ist ja bei unseren MacBooks immer noch aktiv, den hat er für den Quadra gemacht.
Das ist immer noch derselbe?
Das ist immer noch derselbe.
Der hat sich so ein bisschen verändert, hat er sich aber schon über die Zahlen.
Das erzählt er ja unter anderem auch. Der Quadra hatte den und das war die erste Änderung am Startup Sound, die sie seit dem Mac 2 gemacht haben. Und der wirklich furchtbar war. Und dann fing das so plötzlich an, dass jeder neue Mac einen neuen Sound hatte. Und als Steve Jobs zurückkam, hat er gesagt, ab sofort alle Rechner wieder mit dem guten Sound. Und das war der vom Quadra. Also der hört quasi diesen Sound, den er damals gemacht hat, an dem er ein paar Tage gesessen hat, den hört er nach wie vor auf ihrem Rechner. Und der erzählt auch mal nochmal die schöne Geschichte, die ich immer so als Gerücht gehört hatte und nie wusste, ob es so stimmt, vom Susumi-Sound. Kennst du die Geschichte? Wollen wir die hier erzählen in dem Rahmen oder wollen wir die für das Interview drin lassen?
Ach du meinst, ob wir jetzt hier zu viel spoilern?
Genau.
Also ich, soweit ich weiß, hat das eben, ist es halt dieses Susumi, schon dieses Wortspiel mit irgendwie Verklagt mich doch. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, woher das kam.
Es kam daher, erzählen wir jetzt doch das, dass Apple ja damals heftigen Trouble hatte mit Apple Records, weiß ich nicht, also diese Beatles. Und die mussten, Apple musste sich verpflichten, niemals irgendwas mit Musik zu machen. Und da waren sie kurz davor, Mac OS System 7 rauszubringen. Und da war halt ein Sound dabei und der hieß, ich weiß nicht, Xylophon oder irgendwie sowas. Und da hat dann jemand aus der Legal-Abteilung gesagt, hui hui hui hui, ein Sound namens Xylophon.
Das ist aber schon fast Musik.
Das ist ja schon fast ein Musikinstrument.
Ach und deswegen haben sie ihn dann Sosumi genannt.
Und daraufhin mussten sie sich dann neu unternehmen, ah, schmeiß den Sound raus, schmeiß den Sound raus. Und daraufhin hat er dann gesagt, er hat den verkauft als, also das erzählt sich auch nochmal sehr schön, er durfte es halt ihnen nicht vorsprechen, sondern er hat den Brief geschrieben an die Apple-Legal-Abteilung, also eine Mail, wir nennen den jetzt so, damit die nicht auf den Trichter kommen, weil in dem Moment, in dem er es ausgesprochen hätte, Sosumi, wären sie vielleicht drauf gekommen, dass das ja eine Aufforderung ist, gegen den Vertrag zu verstoßen. Und ja, das ist die Geschichte von diesem Sound. Und das ist sehr schön, der kann die ganz wisslich erzählen, und er sieht dabei immer so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Frosch, der... Und der hat auch, also bei diesem Welcome to Macintosh, das ist nämlich auch eine ganz schöne Geschichte, der erzählt so, bei Apple zu arbeiten ist wie in einer Marmeladenfabrike. Genießt das Ergebnis, aber du willst nicht wissen, wie es entsteht. Du willst es nicht wissen.
Ja, das ist wie bei Podcasts.
Wir reden ja normalerweise gar nicht miteinander.
Wenn ihr wisst, wie dieser Content hier entsteht, ihr würdet gar nicht wissen.
Denn es ist nicht da, der ist einfach tot.
Gut, nachdem wir Dennis erfolgreich abgehalten haben, mir dumme Kommentare zu geben, wollen wir Schluss machen, oder?
Genau.
Hey, wir sind unter zwei Stunden, Mann. Ja. Das ist gut. Da haben wir nämlich auch nicht mehr sehr viel mehr Zeit, aber wir haben uns doch durchgerungen, hier eine Sendung zu machen, sodass wir unseren zwei-Wochen-Takt noch so halbwegs aufrecht erhalten können. Ja, in diesem Sinne sagen wir schön Tschüss. Und bis bald.
Ich schmeiß den Link jetzt noch mal in den Chat.
Bis bald, bis zur nächsten Ausgabe. Ciao!